in this course Guillaume will teach you
how to use the Tailwind CSS framework to
create web applications faster and
easier Guillaume has been a front-end
developer for 10 years and he has
created many courses on udemy and his
own YouTube channel hello everybody and
welcome to this course about Tailwind
CSS my name is Guillaume and today I'm
going to introduce you to this amazing
CSS framework made to create design for
front-end application
I'm going to use nexgs during this
course however you don't need to know
anything about next to follow every step
of the course it's the same for CSS you
don't necessarily need to know CSS to
follow this course however it's
recommended to have some bases by the
end of this entire demonstration you
will be able to use Tailwind CSS to
create your own custom design system
here is the program of our course we are
going to learn how to deal with color at
first because Tailwind CSS is providing
to us a full set of colors that are very
useful then we are going to see how to
customize your design because yes with
tear in CSS what is amazing is that
there is a powerful engine of
customization that helps you to
customize everything
then we are going to look at the
typography how to deal with text size
and text fonts those spaces and sizes of
merging and padding we are going to deal
with flags and grids to create columns
for instance or just to create
containers
then we are going to look at the layouts
and the layouts it's something really
important when we do front-end
application sometimes we want to switch
our Styles this is what we are going to
see then we are going to look at the
borders the effects filters animation
and transition if you did CSS before you
should be familiar with these Concepts
and of course we will need to take a
look at the core concept of telwyn
because if you want to work with
Tailwind CSS I think this is my personal
opinion you need to understand the core
concept to use it efficiently finally we
will finish by create our own design
system we will create together some
buttons some select elements entirely
with Tailwind of course we will not miss
to see how we can implement the famous
dark mode Let's Start right now
to follow this course I created a next
gs14 application but you can also follow
this course with vue.gs as well yes and
any other front-end framework that you
want that you like and use also Tailwind
it's not a problem you can install
Tailwind everywhere you want to do front
end or either you want to do an HTML
using an HTML file it's also working
when we go on 10win css.com WE quickly
understand that terrain CSS is providing
to us already CSS written so basically
here we got the classes that we apply to
an HTML
file or UI element whatever and we see
that the design is dynamically updated
so basically the Tailwind CSS core team
already write all the CSS we need and
that we use most of the time to create
element so we don't waste time on on
writing CSS it's already here so why not
use it so there are several ways to
install Tailwind so you can use the CLI
provided by Tailwind itself it's the
tool that helps you to install
everything
but me I'm going to use one of the
framework guides here with nexgs as you
see here there is well kit angular
Phoenix solid GS Gatsby whatever it will
work for you then we got also the CDN if
you want to use it for instance in a
single HTML file or for an email
template or a plugin whatever you can
use also Tailwind by importing the
script so I'm going to go on the
framework guide click on next GS even
though I know that it's not really
complete now because I'm using Nexus 14
and I will have to Loop through my app
folder so I'm going to be here and what
I'm going to use is directly the
installation here that we got npm
install
minus the Tailwind CSS I'm going to stop
all of this
but CSS Auto prefixer it's really
important then I'm going to get back
here and I need to init my Tailwind CSS
files because terrain CSS comes with
configuration file the force of Tailwind
is that you can customize everything
before pre-processing your CSS final
style sheet what does it mean it means
that here in my tailwind.config.js I can
do a lot of configuration on colors
spacing
typography font family whatever that
will help me to on the Fly
rebuild my CSS library and get my own
customization available inside Tailwind
so I'm gonna get back there and in order
to do so I need to specify to Tailwind
where to look at and where to get the
files and to update them and pause them
and see where are the classes that they
can you can use I'm going to get back on
tailwind config.js and we see here that
my content array is empty I need to put
here pages and components because if you
are using nexgs 12 or the version before
the the last version which is the Nexus
13. you have the pages folder that
contains tons of files with extension GS
typescript gs6 TS6 and components also
that contains also files with extension
and basically their Tailwind has to know
that he has to look at this
however here in Nexus 13 we have an Hub
folder we want to look at so I need to
add this up there here in the
documentation it says Nexus 13 V10 plus
project but the documentation at the
time I'm doing this video is not updated
so we need to say look at the app folder
which is here I need to do is to go on
my global.css file and add Tailwind with
the at decorator tell win I will call
telwyn and say please bring me something
and here it's base then we import
components and utilities we need all
those elements to make Tailwind Works
inside our app so in global.css I
removed the previous code that I have
when I generate my next gs13 app and I
had my Tailwind there all done there I
got an example
I'm going to copy paste this piece of
gs6 there and instead of a I'm going to
just copy paste this LOL now I'm going
to type yarn Dev I'm going to make my
application running I'm going to get
back and then when I update I'm supposed
to have Tailwind CSS loaded it is
working and if I want to check if
Tailwind has been imported I go to my
source tab in my console on localhost
here I can go to next static which is
here which is the build of my app I go
to CSS and when I click on
app.global.css we see that I got
Tailwind CSS running
one of the main core concept of terrine
CSS is utility classes
basically with HTML what should we do
and using a traditional approach for an
element you will first write HTML and
from parent to Children you will Target
these HTML element with classes
then what you will do you will write CSS
and dcss will be related to your HTML
element
so you will write one time CSS for one
element
with tearing CSS we get the same result
way faster with a lighter code base
because we are using utility classes
utility classes its classes already
provided by Tailwind CSS to give the
same result but without writing any CSS
if you want to use flexbox
padding Max width margin background
color border radius with eight Flags
whatever you can relate to the Tailwind
CSS documentation and just add your
classes this way so you will ask me the
question Guam why not to use inline
style instead of having those classes
well telwyn CSS has many advantages over
inline Style
first you have a predefined design
system provided by Tailwind which means
that from the start if you don't want to
create a design system you can easily
use the pre-existing design system
then with tear in CSS you can focus on
responsive design from the start
so I give you an example you are
creating your application and you are
adding your classes for the desktop Tab
and mobile you can do it with responsive
design at the same time because Tailwind
is providing to you
breakpoint prefixes and those breakpoint
prefixes are simply media queries here
we see that we've got a width by default
and we want to change this width by
default when we reach the breakpoint
prefix medium which is 768 pixel I can
just add the modifier MD on front of it
and I will change the size when I will
be on Min width
768 pixels okay and you can do the same
with large x large etc etc
so terrain CSS is very useful to work
with responsive design immediately from
the start so you don't lose your time
writing first the CSS for desktop then
writing the CSS for responsive
I was talking about modifiers
but modifiers also work for hover focus
and all other elements that you can have
in CSS let's give an example here I get
a button and when I pass my mouse on it
we see that the color is changing okay
it this is because I use the LTT classes
with a modifier hover and with the
modifier over I can say change your
color
it's also working with focus and active
and it's also working with elements like
last hold and even okay here we've got
the the example we can just change the
behavior on when we want to Target the
first last element
etc etc it's also working with before
and after sudo element yes Tailwind work
with pseudo element and we can also
Target for instance the placeholder if
you want to put them in italic the list
markers that's an example or the
Highlight text here I want to change the
color of my highlight text I can do it
with Tailwind simply with the modifier
selection
the responsive breakpoints help us to
work with that because you can stack you
can stack actually the modifiers and the
utility classes which is very useful
but another topic where terrain CSS is
amazing it's it's dark mode with
terrances you can add what we call the
prefers color schema you can have
several
um different color schema to your
Tailwind team and you can use of course
the dark mode here we've got an example
we can say that in dark mode I want to
change a color background and I just had
a dock on top of it okay and that's
amazing because Tailwind CSS really
hacked this thing of having a dark mode
into your application or website
personally I use it all the time however
the real Force for me of Terror in CSS
it's its customization system
we tell you in CSS you can customize all
of it all your framework actually you
can customize your team through a
tailwind.config.js file because Tailwind
is like an engine that will understand
what sizes what colors what font family
what borders you want to use and it will
build on the fly on its basis classes
the class that you need let me give you
an example
on your tailwind.config.js you will have
a team object which will contain the
screen size or the breakpoints that we
saw before but also the colors the font
family and if you want to keep the basis
of terrain and right on top of it you
can use extend and in extend just
rewrite what you just want to write
again
but if you want to create your own team
which is cool is that with the colors
you can say hey if there is no blue
color add this blue color and this is
the code of the color
and the engine of Tailwind will
dynamically create for you the
background the text color the borders
everything that is related to colors and
then you will just have later to type
text blue BG blue border blue etc etc
how amazing is this and since I've I
have started to use tailwind and use its
customization system I cannot work
without of course you can go way deeper
into the customization because with
Tailwind CSS you can just reuse your
style so here we've got an example
here we are targeting the layer base
after importing tailwind and we can
apply with The Decorator add and apply
the directive we can say hey I want to
create a class but I want that this
class is using an existing Tailwind
class you can do it with apply okay you
can go deeper by creating also your
component directly and using the
directive and function theme this
directive and function team is helping
you to Target
directly the basis of tailwind and say
hey I want the reference of the colors
and in the colors I want the white color
and that's sometimes very very useful it
helps you actually to add your custom
utilities and it helps you to add your
custom classes most of the time you see
that you are using the same classes and
stuff and you would like to gather them
into some class it's possible with apply
but also you could create a class with
apply and calling all the base that you
need from Tailwind plus adding your own
CSS so you can stack the base of
Tailwind plus your custom element and
your Custom Design if you want to go
deeper into the customization of
Tailwind you have also the option of
writing plugins in JavaScript
that will help you to basically change
your base or change your component and
utilities provided by Tailwind all right
here we've got a quick example on how I
can change all the H1 of my base my
components there and utilities down
there that's an example on how far you
can go to write CSS with tailwind and
how far you can customize it
let's start by the colors Tailwind CSS
give us
a big palette since the beginning so we
can start
with these colors already provided by
tailwind and which is cool here it's
that we've got for instance this slate
color there and we've got different
gradients okay and it's the same for
every color down there so let's say that
we would like to use for instance this
green color there okay what I can do is
back in my app and I'm going to get back
in the piece of code I just paste okay I
got here
do some classes okay here text minus
free Excel actually it's a class related
to the size then we've got font bold
it's really easy to understand it's a
class related to the wave of the actual
um string then we got underline let's
remove all of this okay
and let's start by an empty class for
this uh piece of string so there we get
back to the app and we've got hello
world just written in here so I'm going
I think I'm going to zoom in there we go
LOL and let's say that we want to apply
this green color
Well normally what we would do is we
would create a CSS class called dot
green and we would put the code color
the X color there inside our class but
what we can do with Tailwind because
it's already written for us
we can go here and type text text means
that we call the variable text which is
inside telwyn and it is waiting for an
action to be done so we are going to put
a minus or Dash and then here what we
can do is put the color we want so I'm
going to type green I'm using the
intellisense extension of vs code so
basically it's really important if you
want to use tailoring CSS in vs code
please use intellisense extension so you
type intellisense there and I'm going to
open this
down there here I got Tailwind CSS
intellisense telwyn CSS intellisense
extension help us to auto complete to
linked to correct our terwin CSS code
written inside our vs code
so here I got nothing that is showing
because text green doesn't mean anything
for Tailwind which means that here I
gotta put
another information to tell him which
kind of color I want to use do I want to
use the 50 the 100 the 200 the 300 the
400 the 500 which one do I need to use
so what I'm going to do I'm gonna need
to use the
600. so I'm going to get back on my app
and put a text green minus 600 sorry it
copied the code and here look
intellisense understood that I want to
use the text green 600 and so it shows
to me this little square there with the
color so I'm going to get back in there
and when I update
the color has been applied and let's
just let's just
inspect this element and look what is in
our console so I'm going to move because
here you don't see it I'm just in front
of it here we've got the color there
with something really weird
for real beginners the RGB code with the
variable TW text opacity
what is that text green 600 is a CSS
class that comes from app.globals App
underscore Global CSS and if I click on
it look at it I'm back inside my
Tailwind CSS main file it's full of
content
and at the end of this content a new
class has been created text green 600
which is really cool because if you
understand well
back in there in the color palette we
got several classes there that exist
that are provided by Green
but actually we got only 600 so it means
that Tailwind only create and picks the
code it needs to run it doesn't have
every color if you don't use them it's
just adding the color you need and we
can make the test there by creating for
instance let's create a div
let's create another title but with a
different color and here for instance I
think we got yellow and there we go we
see that we get yellow
and when I get back I'm going to close
this
I update
and look at this down there we've got
text yellow 600 that has been aided and
that's what is really cool with Tailwind
Tailwind is going to create the classes
it only needs which means at the end you
will not have a big CSS file that you
don't use or you only use 10 percent you
will use 100 that is provided in here
and all the main stuff that you really
need so this was for the text color but
let's say that we want to put a
background
which is amazing with Tailwind it's that
it always worked the same way instead of
having text green 600 let's say that we
want to have for instance BG green 600
which means bg4 background and then we
are going to put a text white there
because we want to have a text White BG
this entry here is telling to my H1 to
apply a background of what green 600 and
I'm gonna get back there I'm going to
update and look at that there we go
we've got our background how amazing is
that it's really easy to understand and
that's what I like about Terror in CSS
is that you can really switch from some
classes that you will use for the colors
the text the grid that we will see later
really easily because once you
understand this Tailwind CSS is really
easy to handle let's say now that
instead of having
this background green we want to have a
border and it really happens often so
I'm going to remove all of this and if I
type border and I get back and I update
there we go we see that we got a border
and this random border has been applied
directly from Tailwind so let's say that
this border we want it to be thicker
what we can do is put a dash and we are
not going to use 50 or 100 or whatever
we are just going to use the size of the
pixel so here let's say that we want to
have six pixels if I type border 6 when
I update
it doesn't apply why so let's go let's
go to the documentation and let's type
border
and let's look at the border and which
is cool with the Tailwind documentation
it's that down there we've got the
classes that are provided directly by
Tailwind
and we have some sizes already made
there so I can only use 0 2 4 8 or just
one and if I want to use other borders
if I don't want to have border that
takes all I can use minus error we're
going to see that just after minus L for
left minus bottom B4 bottom
etc etc so I'm going to get back there
and put a minus
four get back and when I update there we
go I got my border there but remember we
want our border to be green so I'm going
to get back there and type border green
and look at that intellisense is
grabbing all the colors
that we've got so I'm going to type
colors there
all the colors that we've got here
directly inside my
vs code so I'm going to type 600 I'm
going to save
and I'm going to update and the Border
green has been applied okay that's cool
but let's see now how can we deal
with custom colors so I'm going to go on
Google there and I'm going to type Color
Picker and I'm going to take a random
green okay let's say that I want to have
this particular green there and I got
the code down there on the X how can I
do to say to tell when to use this color
what I can do is customizing my color so
I'm going to click here on using
customize color and here we see that we
have to go on
tailwind.config.js file so I'm going to
get back there and I go to
terwin.config.js file and this is where
all the customization magic happens so
what I can do
is enter my team so I got a team that is
open and I already got extended okay X10
sorry so X10 here will be used later to
improve the actual model but if I want
to put a new color there what I can do
is let's say that here I got my view GS
oh I'm on next but I'm going to use
let's say that I'm going to add a new
color so I'm going to type colors there
and I'm going to type my view GS green
color okay and here what I can do is
putting directly my color on there and
I'm going don't need to do that actually
there we go now I got Vue GS as a color
available and when I get back to my app
this is what happens
I don't got the old colors anymore
why because I overwrite the colors from
the team there so I overwrite my colors
and there are two solutions to that I
can either re-import the colors from the
Tailwind the main Tailwind not modules
that I already got otherwise I need to
put those colors into extent because X10
is the option to say okay I keep the
original Tailwind library but I want to
add this this on top of it so I can take
colors there go to extend and put my
colors inside of it instead of having on
the top of team and when I get back I
got my colors back so what I can do here
directly is to go inside my app folder
there and go to my page and instead of
having this this text yellow 600 I'm
going to put text viewgs and here look
intellisense and understood that we want
this green color and when I update I got
my own color so this is how it works
to get the customization colors that we
need and of course inside this vgs we
could do the same as Tailwind we could
say that 100 is this color okay
but we could say for instance that
932 is the uh is another color let's say
uh yes there we go let's say it's this
one and when I will use that there I can
do text viewgs 100
with this color and also I can use the
other color with my own key that I
created inside my extend there
on the official documentation of
Tailwind on the customization side
we see that we can configure the
customization we can also customize the
content our teams do screens the colors
the spacing we can add plugins and
presets
and if we start by the main file of
telwyn which is
tailwind.config.js we see down there
that we can configure the colors
the font family but also those facing
the Border radius etc etc
means yes
classes
is referred to
CSS and this CSS
is actually generated on the fly so on
the
tailwind.config.js file you can write as
keys of these objects
you can write classes and those classes
will irritate from the value of this key
and sometimes this value Can Be Strings
numbers or objects or array as we see
down here on font family we have a font
that is added which is graphic and then
we've got some serif so we see that some
serif would be the second argument of
font family basically here font family
saw with graphic and saucerif will make
for us a fun family semicolon graphic
sensitive okay
nothing really special there but which
is cool is that you can also customize
the spacing
so the spacing with tearing CSS and it's
a very important concept
help us to deal with the padding the
merging the with the eight etc etc
so we see there that immediately we can
say that the spacing that we are looking
for can be defined there as pixels Ram
or any other unit here we've got the
example of a team that specify the size
of for instance our screens I want to
put a certain size on the sentence okay
so I'm going to put text Dash to say
that I want this text to be text LG or
what happens if I put another size here
we see that my code editor already
corrected me we got two different sizes
and there is a conflict what I can do
with Tailwind is that I can say that I
want to have text SM but when I'm on LG
so when I'm on a large screen
semicolon I want to have text LG okay
so here text is SM will be applied to
all the sizes of the screen that are
lower to LG and if I go to my
tailwind.config.js I can add the example
that I have there on my team so I'm
going to take this screens okay on my
team and I'm going to add it and I'm
going to save Tailwind CSS understand
that all those size have a limit a media
query limit
of this value every time to make a big
difference on that what I'm gonna do is
to expand the size so I'm going to have
text 6X and here I'm going to put text
free excels and so there's a moment when
I'm going to switch and there we go I'm
going to get back there and I'm going to
move again and look here up there you
get the size okay of the screen the
current screen so we see that I'm moving
the size and when I pass the limit which
is 976 okay
176 we see that my text is changing this
is because LG has been defined there as
976. let's give another example now
let's say that on MD I'm going to put an
alternative and here I want to have a
text LG and let's say that on small I'm
going to have a text base okay I'm going
to save this I'm going to pass step by
step to all those sizes I'm going to get
back
and I'm going to
get back there and please have a look in
here on the size and when I lower the
size okay little by little I'm going to
pass from
a size to another one and look here it's
really easy to see we change the size
dynamically it's also working for colors
it's also working for font family and
this is something really useful instead
of having JavaScript function that help
us to change classes
attribute whatever we can use steroine
for that here on the documentation
we see that the behavior can change
there when we specify a width and of
course those width are provided by
terwin but you can change them customize
them if you want to or if you need to
it's exactly the same for spacing on
spacing here you can specify that some
elements there can have a specific
spacing all right and those numbers
specific numbers that are used so if I
go here
and I put my spacing sorry object there
with this this spacing would be applied
to all classes that are calling as an
argument do spacing here we got two
sentences and we want to put some space
under the first sentence when I go to my
page I apply a margin bottom of one to
understand how to add margin padding and
spaces please refer to the video spaces
in my tailwind.config.js I said that the
spacing one die that I applied here as
an argument of the class
is 8 pixel but just for the example
let's put 100 pixel and let's get back
to our application and updating and here
we see that now the spacing with one is
of 100 pixel so you can build
your entire system of spacing with
tailwind and this is really amazing
because tearing is by nature providing
uh already made spacing grid but
actually if you have a different vision
and if the design system that has been
given to you by a graphic designer for
instance is different from Tailwind
actually you can build a new design
system directly there with your own
spacing way deeper into the
customization possibilities
with Tailwind you can create what we
call plugins and plugins
it's some kind of helpers that helps you
to create style sheets with JavaScript
so it can be useful in many many
situations if you want to create some
elements such as utilities such as
components match component add-base add
variants let's say that you want to go
way deeper into the work of a front-end
developer and create really really
specific design you would need to create
what we call a plugin to our arbitrary
values well its values that you can
directly
inject into the CSS class that you get
there so let's take an example let's
take this background color there which
is not part of my customization file
okay I just put that and we see that
intellisense already recognized the
color okay and when I save and I get
back to the app there we go my color has
been applied so this arbitrary values
are values that you use not necessarily
everywhere but you set up directly
inside the current
CSS class there and that's what is cool
with Tailwind we can also build on the
Fly Like This
without registering all the values that
we want to customize inside
tailwind.config.js we can build our
design system like this directly in line
what we call inline style directly into
the HTML using 10 win CSS is amazing
because it provides to us a lot of
classes already written CSS that we can
use but do we really need to never write
CSS sometimes we do we need to write CSS
Tailwind is providing to us a directive
call layer so when I go to my global.css
file and I'm going to close all of this
to be clear there we go
we can apply layer okay layer is a
directive that help us to write CSS for
a certain scope up there we uh we
imported actually Tailwind already so
layer here is available there and down
there we see that
layer okay can add style to Tailwind
base component and utilities and
remember base component and utilities
are on the top they are imported and I
can overwrite here on by typing layer
base see that I want to have
background color yes and let's put for
instance lime all right if I get back to
my app what's gonna happen
I go here I update and there we go we've
got the color uh that it has been
applied there instead of writing this I
can use apply apply the directive help
me to call actually to call
do classes that are provided by Tailwind
so here we see that I have an apply text
to excel but let's say that we want to
do apply BG and let's say BG uh let's
put a gray slate there we go and I'm
going to say like this I'm going to get
back there and remove this class that I
had previously removing it and there we
go I get back I update and what's gonna
happen is that
I have my background in Gray so what
happened here is that I can call
as much as I want
10 win classes so I can call text white
for instance and there we go
so here at the beginning of a project
I should go to taiwin.config.js adding
all my classes spaces typography and
when I want to do really custom CSS
I can go back on my global.css and apply
my class there for soft Tailwind for me
it's using this apply directive what we
can do we can chain actually we can
chain the classes there so we earn
visibility
time and our code is more clear more
easy to understand and I'm going to do a
text LG so I think text LG yeah text LG
and font bold all right so when I get
back there we go my steel has been
applied another function that I should
mention here is that you can use
multiple CSS files and by that you can
mention them in your post CSS import if
you don't want to write CSS you can
focus on writing plugins so as I told
you plugins are JavaScript functions
basically that will help you to write
CSS by JavaScript you can find it here
on writing plugins on the official
documentation
we can see that we have several elements
that can help us to change the font or
text inside our application of course
the team core of Tailwind thought about
everything concerning typography
in my next GS application I have
different uh type of tag elements there
I have an H1 for the first title I have
an H2 an H3 and then I have several
paragraph and the first thing that we
can notice is that Tailwind CSS doesn't
apply the regular styling of the title
with the tag the tags H1 H2 H3
those titles were supposed to be in bold
and with a higher font size and here
with Tailwind it's totally recessed so
basically what we would need to do is to
change at first the size and how can we
change the size with Tailwind I using
text minus or Dash and the size we want
to have so let's try let's apply those
classes and let's see what's going to
happen so I'm going to take the first
class text excess that gives the font
size of
0.75 Ram so 12 pixel I'm going to take
it I'm going to get back there and down
there we see that I've already created a
class called not okay we will see that
later but I'm going to add text excess
okay and my code editor in intellisense
already changed the order of the class
so now I add text success on this little
note back into my application
when I update we see that the size of
the last paragraph changed and it
changed for a smaller size so when I
inspect and I go there we see that the
font size is now
0.75 RM so Tailwind is providing to us
many different font sizes class that we
can use and let's go gradiently so here
I'm going to get back add my class name
there which is text small which is
supposed to be bigger than the text
excess I'm going to update and there we
go and for the regular font size of
terwin we add text base there so I'm
going to take a base yes text base there
this way there we go and there we go so
we've got now the regular paragraph that
stays on the same size the first three
titles still stay at a certain font size
so here we can one ram but if I go there
we see that let's go and computed
that the font size is still 16 pixels so
what I can do is to use text LG but
basically by experience on Tailwind to
use the size of uh some titles we will
use text Excel so I'm going to get a
bigger size and on the text free there I
will add my text Excel there and we see
that the title is bigger and when I go
here I look at it I'm on 20 pixel
uh on top of excel we can add a number
okay there is no text x6o with Tailwind
you will have to add a number on front
of the Excel there and it goes to nine
so let's take the latest and see what is
the size of of 9 XL and we will see will
be big and let's say that here it's
going to be text to excel so we've got
three titles here and those titles
having different sizes so 9 XL and
there's a gap between the two and the
nine there so I'm going to get back
update and suddenly we have this big
title there so you understand that
there's a limit and actually I'm going
to get back on 100 we understand that
there's a bigger limit that has been
crossed between the first title and the
second title there all right so
basically you would not have this kind
of Gap in terms of design because it's
too much what you need to do is trying
to stay in the same in the same range of
the sizes okay and there we go when we
update there we go that's we have so for
the font sizes it's very interesting
okay we see here that we can change the
font size as we want and of course we
can customize our font sizing so let's
try to configure to customize our font
size so I gotta go on team and I'm gonna
add font size so back in my
tailwind.config.js I'm going to type
font size and open an object and what do
I have I have a text base which is there
and right now text base is one REM one
ram it corresponds to 16 pixel so let's
say that I don't want to have 16 pixels
but instead 18 pixel okay so I'm saving
this term to base 18 pixels here I got a
text base which is there I'm going to
unzoom a little bit and right now it's
supposed to be 16 pixels okay I'm going
to put it at 18 pixels all right so I'm
going to save this I'm going to zoom
again there we go
and updating
and what's happening there
my title lost their sizes and just my
paragraph there has been updated so as
you see if you try to change
the the font size is by default in the
team there you will remove the other
sizes so you will have to manually there
manually change every size you are using
so let's take for instance text we've
got SM okay so SM is there and I'm going
to say that SM would be 15 pixel and Xs
would be 12 pixels okay there we go I'm
going to get back and we see that it
changed all right and we can do the same
for the values on the top also so if you
don't want to overwrite those font sizes
what you can do is taking them and put
them into your extend extend will keep
of course the initial configuration and
we just want to write on top of Tailwind
so when I update you see here that what
only changed it's the value I used so
here we got 18 pixels there instead of
16. all right that's great but what
about the font family if I want to use
certain font family to Tradewind CSS is
offering to us the option to customize
our phones okay but also Tailwind CSS
provide to us basic font classes that if
you are on different devices you want to
keep your font secure but what if I want
to import my own font and let's go on
Google phones
and let's say that I want to import a
special font so here I got a phone
selected enter if you want to look for a
font of course you can go click here and
take any font and add it to your review
there what if I want to import this font
enter
I can go here so I'm going to put that
there I'm going to click here and import
my fonts okay I'm going to copy paste
this
get back and go to
myglobal.css is always to import always
your font there on the top then what I'm
going to do getting back there I'm going
to copy paste the the CSS rule to
specify the font feminine that I want to
use and remember there we still have our
layer base
which is used to act on layers that we
use inside tailwind and on my HTML what
I can do is simply apply my font enter
and when I get back and I update and I'm
going to look at it okay what's going to
happen here I got enter as a font so
this is how you use custom font with
Tailwind CSS
if you want to have smoothing on phones
you can use also the class and
digitalize and sub pixel and digitalize
it gives something you see maybe we have
to zoom to see the difference we see
that our phones are a bit thicker or
thinner it depends on the class you are
using about font styling it's exactly
the same you have classes for italic not
italic okay you have also text
decoration there with underline overline
so if I go here and I get back on my
first title let's say that I want it to
be italic I can type italic and when I
update there we go we'll get the title
in italic if I want it underline I can
type underline and suddenly I get an
underline
I can have a line through also which is
a useful when you create some kind of
to-do list that when you click it's
passed on the Statue is done so you can
put a line through like this otherwise
you can have also an over line so as you
see down there we get an example but we
can just put it in there we've got an
over line there
I don't know why we would use that but
it can be useful also and which is
really cool with that text decoration
it's that with Tailwind CSS you can act
on the color the thickness the style of
this underline so if we go there we see
that we've got some examples you can
change the color of the underline and
that's really cool so here I'm going to
change the color just to show it to you
let's say that we want our underline to
be red so I'm going to get back there
and put underline and text decoration
red 800 okay I got a red red 800. so 800
is maybe too much what I'm gonna put is
500 and there we go we're gonna have
yeah it's better and this is how you can
change your color this is really cool
but you can also change the style and I
find it really really funny if you want
to have a double uh decoration you can
use decoration double so here I'm going
to get back decoration double I update
and suddenly I got two lines I can use
dotted also so dotted it will put dots
instead of a regular light and the one
that I like a lot it's wave and wave I
found it really really nice so yeah
decoration wavy sorry I put wave but
it's wavy there we go I'm going to
update we've got a wavy decoration and
by the time if you wanted to do some
kind of wave like this most of the
people will use the pseudo element after
and put some kind of image we take in
CSS it's really easy you just have to
put those classes what you can do also
is work on the decoration thickness so
if you want to have a very pronounced
underline let's take I'm going to take
decoration eight I'm going to get back
there and put decoration eight look at
that I get something really big and the
problem is that it takes a lot of size
and that's not what we want so we can
work also on the offset
and I think I'm going to get back there
and just put a decoration one because
it's too much there we go and let's say
that I want to put a offset
so I have to use underline offset 8 and
what's gonna happen is that it's going
to create space
between the line of my text and the top
of the underline so as you see here I
again I use a very big value but if I
can use the underlying offset 4 I got
something that look nicer and just let's
take that and put it in instead on a
description I think it's better so here
we got a regular paragraph and I'm going
to put it there because most of the time
those are the lines we will use them
inside paragraph there we go we see that
here the G is almost touching the
underline and that's not what we want so
we can augment the offset so when I
update ah we don't have five I think yes
eight there we go so I can I have to put
a eight instead of a four
yeah we got something really bigger and
the thing is that here what we would
like to have is a higher underline okay
a higher underline so what I need to do
is to go actually under line eight and
with Tailwind CSS we can deal with line
eight
so as you see here we got a leading
class with a number three four five that
um make our line 8 bigger
and at the end you get also classes
regular classes that shows that you can
use several sizes that are what we call
regular sizes of line eight those
regular sizes they are based on the
number 1 1.2 1.3 okay and it's a regular
element to um size actually the eight
uh here the light leading three four
five six they are based on Ram or pixels
so I don't think it's really useful it's
I it's preferably for me to use those
leaning there so I'm going to use
leading normal
on my paragraph okay I'm going to get
back there leading no more updating and
here we see it doesn't change because
basically the line a that I already have
there I'm going to go on the style and
I'm going to show it to you this way I'm
going to go there the the line 8 that I
have already is not very accessible okay
so where is it leading normal we got it
in here let's just check together which
is the line eight we would have to get
so I got a line a there and if I put one
we see that my line is on the top of the
next paragraph and we don't want that if
we put two
it's better but suddenly I understand
that my offset is too big I have to get
back on my offset so I'm going to put
four
and maybe yeah it's better so suddenly
we see that we get spaced brief between
that and that's better and what is the
lending leading glues leading glues is
the line eight two okay so I'm going to
update and put my leading loose there
I'm going to save get back
and there we go I got something bigger
the problem is that later on a real
paragraph it will put a lot of eight so
the best thing is always to stay on
normal or preferably on snug instead of
having a a there I'm going to put a with
lowercase and get back and here we see
that my a is lowercase the basic reflex
that you could have is to use capitalize
it's too capitalized all your text and
that's a problem because it will
capitalize not only the first letter
here but the first letter of every word
of the sentence so if I get here and I
put my capitalize class there and I
update we see that air of regular and P
of paragraph have been capitalized that
could be a problem so if you want to
capitalize a whole text you can do it
otherwise you would have to create some
kind of
middleware to Middle refer for the
string to a function that will take the
string and just capitalize the first
letter with a span otherwise the other
thing is that if you want to lower case
what you can do is using lowercase so
I'm going to remove all of this because
you you will not read very well if I put
lowercase what's going to happen is that
even if I put a bigger a I will have a
lowercase on every sharp character of
the sentence
and the last one that I like a lot
because Normal case it's just a normal
case is the uppercase let's say that you
want to have all the sentence on
uppercase
there we go it puts all the sentence on
uppercase let's talk about the text
overflow now sometimes we want to
shorten okay we want to shorten the text
we have and we often create functions to
do it with a substring basically here we
can use truncate so I don't have a very
good example there but I'm going to just
put a paragraph with a long sentence so
this is a long sentence with a lot of
words to explain that
truncate will truncate my sentence all
right I could have put a low Ram ipsum
but I think it's better to do what we
see is that my text is going to the line
automatically there and if I put the
class truncate okay class name truncate
all right what's gonna happen is that
basically on the end of my HTML element
it will not go to the line it will not
wrap that's what we call wrap what's
going to happen there is that truncate
it's going to create a white space with
Nora which means that we don't want
our sentence to break and the overflow
will be hidden okay
so here it's not very nice but let's say
that we would have a div with a style
width of 200 pixels and I'm going to put
that between between yes as a string and
there we go we got here the truncate
that works at the end of our div and if
I go here and I look at it before the
end of my div of 200 pixels it's
substring actually it's substring yes my
sentence and just cut it to do truncate
okay for truncate but ellipses ellipses
here happens when you have a big text
and a big word and you want your big
word to be truncate you can use the
class text ellipses for the clip it's
different it will not wrap your word
your wrong word but it will just cut it
just take it on overflow Eden when you
add overflow Eden to text clip text
overflow help us to deal with words why
white space help us to deal with words
spaces and if you want to wrap or not
your lines basically white space normal
makes that it will have a normal
behavior
no wrap will help us to not wrap our
text so here we've got an example we got
a long sentence and it doesn't wrap so
I'm going to get back there and remove
this
style here that I got and remove also
these things so I'm going to type class
name and then I'm going to use white
space wrap okay the class that we have
sorry white space no wrap
so I got my text which is there I'm
going to use white space no wrap and I'm
going to update and we see that my text
doesn't wrap and I can have another flow
here to scroll from the left to the
right okay it doesn't wrap so it goes
out
of your screen or your limits depending
on what spaces and what limits you
define but yeah white space no wrap is
used for that also what you get
is to use white space pre it's to
preserve new lining spaces within an
element so sometimes you have spaces or
lines that you want to keep you use
white space pre
and also what you can do you can use
white space pre-line which means that
you will get every time you get a space
a line there you get pre-wrap you get a
lot of other options that you can use
there yeah basically a white space
pre-wrap and no wrap are the most used
let's finish by the world break in
terrain CSS you can deal with world
breaking
with those four classes there so let's
say that you have a very long word and
you don't want to break it you can use
break normal it won't break your word so
let's try to use this example that we
get there so I'm going to remove that
and there we go let's put a very long
word just there and let's take the word
of uh the word used by the Tailwind CSS
documentation
so we got it here and basically what
what's happening is that my word is
going to the line and disappear there
okay so we if we want that we just let
it like this or use break normal but if
we want to break the words if they are
too big we can use break words so I'm
going to add this class there break
words and when I update automatically my
big words went to the line because I
really zoomed but if I move my screen
this way and I arrive to the word and
here the word have no other escape from
the size look it will go to the line
directly so to do that you use the break
word class okay otherwise if you want to
break all the words you can use break
all that we got there so I'm going to
get back and use break all and break all
will just fit to the content so there we
see that the the big word that we get
stayed on the first line and
automatically automatically broke so I
go there and look at this and it's going
to move line by line because I have to
break all class
let's start with padding in termin CSS
we got classes that help us to deal with
padding and those classes starts by P P
for padding then we've got a minus and
we've got a number exactly with the
sizes we saw before the number is
representing actually
the size you want to select and here we
got some example of P minus 0 which
represents a padding of zero but before
we talk about padding it's better to
give a definition padding induces the
space inside an element between this
element and its border and it's really
important to understand the difference
between padding and merging padding
concern space inside the element while
margin concerns space outside the
element so if you want to put some space
inside an element you are going to use
padding and Taiwan CSS provide to us
many classes that we can use to create
padding but sometimes you want to put
padding only on the left only on the
right on top or on the bottom
with Tailwind CSS we can deal with that
because it provides classes
for top right bottom or left and here
I'm going to zoom a bit
here we got example when you want to put
a padding top you use pt0 when you want
to use padding right you use pr0 PB for
bottom PL
etc
etc so I got my app that is running
there and I just got a hello there and
what I'm gonna do I'm going to use a new
class and I'm going to put a background
okay this background will be BG red and
I don't think that BG red will work
because I will have to put of course the
weight of the color and when I update
there we go I got my element here that
is in red I'm going to put text white
and a bit of
bolt on the font and when I update there
we go I got my text there so if I want
to put padding inside this red line
there what I just have to do is to type
P minus and here let's try with P minus
one
and what this class is going to do is to
add some space everywhere everywhere
inside my red box and when I pass my
mouse on it and here on the on the
selector that we get there we see that
we have padding inside the red box so we
see that one correspond to four so let's
get back in the official documentation
and let's go down to P1 and we see here
that we've got the description P run
correspond to 4 pixel if I get to
another number like let's say that P4
for instance and I update look at that
now we got more space okay so all of
this is a question on what space do you
want to put on all your box this way all
right so now
let's see that so we got 16 pixels right
now everywhere and if you pass your
mouse there you see that inside my red
box
I got this orange Square okay yeah
actually this orange big border which
represent the padding sorry and I have
this uh inside this part that is not
concerned by the padding which contains
yellow let's say that now I just want to
have
okay padding only on the left what I
would do is to put here
I've just after the p and B for the
minus l l for left it's really easy to
understand and when I get back and I
update we see that now my padding has
been added only only here on the left it
would be the same for the right for the
right I would put a air P air 4 and here
we're not going to see a big difference
there but if I put my mouse there we see
that we got on the top if you see it on
the top right this little square orange
that shows that we get 16 pixels of
padding now for the top it's the same
it's a t okay so I'm going to update and
there we go I got four uh actually Four
it's the unit but it's 16 pixel I get 6
pixel on the top and B okay B for button
and there we go I got also here 16 pixel
on the bottom for the margin it's going
to work exactly the same we will have
just instead n then we will have a t for
top B for bottom etc etc now let's say
that we want to have just the padding on
top and bottom and not on left and right
what we're going to use is y a y for the
axis y simply so when I'm going to
update we see there that I got just the
padding on top and padding on the bottom
for not vertical but horizontal I'm
going to use x and when I update there I
got my padding on the left and on the
right
it's really easy to understand all right
it's really really easy
and here on the official documentation
you get of course all the sizes that are
available and those sizes of padding we
will see it later in this lesson we will
be able to change them of course we will
be able to customize them now that we
saw the padding we have to see the
margin and for the margin it's exactly
the same
the only difference is that actually
it's going to be an m on the top of it
on the on the start of it sorry so if I
put M4 there what I'm going to have is a
space outside and of course outside of
my box I'm not into a background red 500
I think I put yes I don't got the color
background red 500 so I put actually and
here we gonna see it again as you see
merging
around my box so let's just get down
there and let's create a new div and
actually what we're gonna do
is to put this box there so box okay box
with margin all right and I'm going to
save this then down there I'm going to
just to put to see different box with
padding okay and one is going to be blue
the box with margin and the padding will
be red
so I'm going to update and there we go
we see the difference the margin it's
outside of your box and the padding is
there and of course it's exactly the
same so if I want to put a margin on top
and on bottom only and not on the on the
left on the right I put y otherwise I
put X so I'm going to update I got X
there okay and of course you I just want
to have margin on the bottom which
happens often with titles I put okay n b
or otherwise I could put empty M air M
left etc
etc let's take a an example right now
let's say that instead of having a div
we would have an H1 so this is my title
okay and down there I will have a
paragraph This is my paragraph all right
so there I would remove this m I would
remove this background because it's
useless and exactly the same for the
text right just gonna let my font bolt
okay so I go down here we see that I got
a title and I'm going maybe to put a bit
of eight on this title so text to excel
what I would like to have is more space
okay between those two elements even if
the line eight is already enough okay I
already have an enough line eight but if
I want to put some space what I could
use is padding but padding here and
let's take that on a padding bottom we
would have a four value we will add four
in terms of unit there we go the thing
is that here I'm putting space inside as
green inside
my title and we you can do it but it
will be better if instead of a padding
inside we would put instead a margin
bottom of four okay margin it's better
because you push from the outside so for
whatever reason you would like to have
your entire title on the eight like this
and yeah there we go but here we see
that we we got space outside but it's
too much we got too much space so this
is another thing with spacing you got to
be careful because sometimes you're
gonna use some values and you will see
that your design is disproportionate
which means that all the sizes are not
really coherent they there will be no
logic if you use two different sizes
everywhere for a lot of elements also
you can use negative values so here
we've got an example and I'm just going
to copy paste this example because we
got we got it in in here or right so I
got those two elements there I got one
square which is up there and then I got
this other uh div down there and what I
can do also is using negative Okay
negative values and actually we're gonna
change the color because here it's going
to be more clear let's say that we get a
blue one and down there we got a red one
if I want it to be inside of it what I
can do is to play on the sizes okay so
here I would do minus in top of the the
value I want to put either padding or
merging and here I'm going to put margin
and let's say that I want it to be on
the top so on top I want to have a
margin negative top and when I get back
and I update
suddenly my div which is supposed to be
just after the first div is entering the
first div because I used a negative
margin so sometimes you may need to have
negative value you can use these minus
before the classes that you are going to
use to move this element when we talk
about spacing of course we talk also
about space between elements and with
Tailwind we can use also classes related
to space between
here we've got some uh boxes so I
created two boxes with a special eight
and a special width and as you see it's
exactly exactly like margin and padding
telwyn is providing to us sizes on wave
and eight so basically when I go down
there in sizing we see that when I type
w0 it gives a width of w0 pixel when we
talk about sizing of course we talk
about with an eight and exactly like we
saw on padding and margin you can give
sizes 8 with two elements when I go on
with
on the official documentation I see that
Tailwind is providing to us several
classes that works on exactly the same
model as the merging and padding and
what I created already is with 16 816 BG
red 500 box and I created another one
just down there and here we've got two
squares those two squares are created by
those width and as you see as you see I
put width 16 which correspond to 64
pixels and those values are Basics
values provided by Tailwind
here down there we see that we can have
also
several values that goes up differently
from the number that you are going to
path those are called fixed width
but what you have also is percentage
with and basically those percentage
width they work with flex if you want to
know more please refer to my video using
Flex with Tailwind so what I can do I
get those two boxes there and if I type
class name and here I'm going to put
flex those two box will come next to
each other okay and let's say that I
want to give them a width and I want to
give them a wave that will take alph of
the screen and instead of having 16
there what I can say to them please take
half of it one slash two
and when I update there we go we see
that my two divs okay
are taking 50 each of the space of the
the current uh div on flex but actually
I could have different behavior let's
take for example this one let's say uh
that on five colons I would have here
two on Five and down there of course the
latest would have what three columns
because the difference between two and
five here is three so I would have here
a lower column than this one so let's
say that here is going to be a sidebar
and here it's with main content which
happens most of the time back into my
application when I update there we go I
got a sidebar which is very big because
it's
two of five columns actually what I
would need to have is instead let's say
one of five colon but what's gonna
happen here is that we are missing a
column there so don't make the mistake
okay here to miss one space because they
win will wait for another one here we
are supposed to have four on five
and now let's see when we move our
content as you see on the responsive
side we have colons that are adapting
themselves so sometimes that can be a
problem because in the sidebar you will
have content and this content will maybe
overflow let's talk now about d8 it's
exactly the same so Tailwind is
providing to us basic 8 that we can use
and most of the time it's really useful
so here we already used a height of 16
okay but look we can have other eight
that we can use that are proportionally
bigger or not of course we have with an
8 but we also have Min width so you can
play with Min width you get several
classes that can be applied to the
content so sometimes you would like to
have a mean width of the content so here
let's say that we would have a mean with
Min content so what I would do there
instead of having this I would have mean
with me there we go and we see that the
sidebar took the size actually of its
co-locating div so here if I lower the
size size of d8 actually sorry of my
main content what is going to happen is
that my sidebar is going to stick to the
8th of my content so you use for that
mean with Min which says that he wants
to irritate from the mean content of its
parent element it's exactly the same for
Max width the main difference is that on
Max width you have several other classes
okay
that just says that we want to have for
instance Max with full so the big
content there will take only okay the
maximum width of the current browser
so let's take an example and let's say
that here our main content we want to
put a margin there and maybe this margin
we're going to give it a big margin okay
72 so I'm going to save
and when I update we see that I got a
big margin and if I remove my with foot
and I just put my Flex there and I save
okay
let's take an example we have our
sidebar and our main content there and
let's say that we want to put a Max
width and this one is going to be here
we've got some example
Excel LG MD whatever I'm going to put
Excel and here so the name what we're
going to see is that my content okay has
been reduced to excel otherwise other
classes that we can use is Max with mean
Max with the current attribute of CSS
with Max with Min content Max content
feed content otherwise we see down there
that we have also classes with actually
media queries and on different screens
that we can have
here we've got our sidebar main content
and we've got this big white uh
background there and let's say that we
would like to have actually the sidebar
okay on the on on the full eight
actually and the main content the same
what we could use is min 8 screen which
will refer actually to 100 VH so let's
say that we are going to take Min H
screen okay and we want to put it just
on the sidebar what I can do so I'm
going to remove this mean age screen
okay we'll say that actually we want to
take the full 8 for the sidebar and
sometimes you will need to do that but
of course what we could do also is to
actually just put that on the parent so
when I put that on the parent here we
don't see any difference because I got a
hate on my main content there so I'm
going to remove this get back and there
we go now
all the children of my parents and God
mean eight screen are full screen by
default and it's also working of course
if you want to apply mean 8 with Min
content Max content fit content on Min 8
mean exactly with the max value one of
the most interesting characteristic of
spacing and sizing inside tell when CSS
comes now it's about space between
elements
what you would do if you would like to
have space between sidebar and Main
content is basically putting
margin or the padding it depends on how
you would do it actually you are not
obliged
tearing CSS is providing to us space
between classes that help us to create
space between elements and it's doing it
in a smart way when we go down we get an
example here we can use space minus X it
reminds you the horizontal spacing that
we can do with padding and margin and
for as a value so if I do if I do that
on my actual app
I should write up there next to flex
space minus X and let's put four and
let's see what is going to happen to our
children's sidebar and Main content
actually we got space that has been
created and it has been created in a
smart way which means that it's going to
be equally uh put between the two sides
all right and that's the beauty of it
with flex you use space between so we've
got other example just try to use space
Y8 here as an example so now we worked
horizontally we want to work vertically
so if I put space y 4 we have only this
one that is apply and why do we have
only this one which is apply it's
because main content is supposed to be
the second element so if I put a flex
color there and I want my two element
being on top of each other
we've got a different Behavior but we
see that space has been put in here so
you will ask to me what is the
difference between margin and or padding
and this space actually it's margin here
and what is the difference
visually there is no difference however
you don't want to have margin but a
margin top everywhere all the time
especially between elements like these
columns and Main content Etc so with
flex you are using space between to
create spaces between elements about the
customization it's really easy to
understand on my next GS application I
got several titles and those titles have
different margin class there on the
bottom and it's going to order of
matters for three two one there and I
see that my mp4 is at one REM and let's
say that I would like to actually lower
this size and what I can do is to go on
my tailwind.config.js
and in X10 I can create a margin
entrance so here I'm going to remove
this font size I'm going to put the
margin and let's say that now what I
want to have is that mb4 okay
mb4 would be actually
20 pixels
so I'm going to save get back and when I
update we see that we clearly see that
the size of my margin changed and here
we've got 20 pixels instead of one REM
you would do exactly the same for every
size and you see that it's also working
for arbitrary values that we can put
between brackets so here on every of my
size I would lower the value every time
so here it's going to be 18 pixels for
actually free okay then for 2 it would
be 16 and for one it would be by D4 14.
so when I get back there and I update
after the update we can check that every
size of the margin there will be applied
from my Tailwind configuration and you
can also do it for all the extended
sizing classes
of course retailing CSS we can deal with
flex Flex is a CSS property that helps
us to put elements next to each other or
to pick the order of the element that we
want to show we can also work with
columns rows etc etc to display the
elements in the order that we want
so basically on terwin CSS and here I
get my app running what I'm going to do
is I'm going to use the classes to
trigger a specific order on my div
so I got a parental div up there and
what I want to do I want to create a
first div that will be actually my main
content all right and what I want to
have also is a div that is going to be
my sidebar
so I got those two divs inside a parent
okay and let's say that this one we are
going to call it parent okay and those
two one are children all right
so when I get back to my app
I got those two div on top of each other
they are like a colon okay they are not
in a row they are like a color
and what I would like to have is
basically to have this sidebar next to
the main content because I want to have
my sidebar on the side so what I can do
is to use the property Flex
with the property Flex provided by
Tailwind CSS I'm adding to the parents
a display Flex on the CSS so when I get
back we see now that my main content and
my sidebar are now on the same row and
if I open my console and I look at these
elements all right I got Flex there and
what I got is this purple
um rectangle all along there that shows
that on the same rule you're align every
element on the width that is
automatically assigned or on the width
that you picked up previously
and if I look there on the um on the
cssr so I'm going to move again uh we
have there the display Flex that has
been applied now I want to add a header
I get back and what I'm gonna do on the
top I'm going to create a new class a
new div sorry with inside Adder and when
I get back the thing is that now I got a
new div and in this new div
here I'm on my parents and what a parent
did a parent has a display Flex
so it put every div that he has inside
of him and he put them inside the same
Rule and this is not what we want
actually what we want is to have the
header on the first row then the main
content and the sidebar on the second
rule because we want our header to be on
the top of these two elements main
content and sidebar so what I can do is
to remove my Flex there
but instead what I'm going to have is a
sidebar on the bottom almost like a
footer and that's not what I want what I
can do is to wrap those two elements
into another div okay I can wrap my main
content and my sidebar in a flex
there any Flex element and I got exactly
what I want
suddenly I got my main content and my
sidebar on a row and I got my header on
another row
so this is how you can organize your
application with flex property
and there's a lot of other elements we
will see that we can use
if I go on Flex Direction I see that I
got several ways of displaying my Flex
divs so here I got a first way which is
flex Rule and it applies a flex
Direction row to my element so there I
already got my two elements next to each
other okay and if I had my Flex rule in
here Flex rule nothing will change
because main content inside bar with
flex I are already on the same row all
right but if I look there I get also a
flex call and flex curl actually
this is like if I didn't have any flex
and what's gonna happen it's it's going
to create a colon there so instead of
having this I can let flex and here I
can let for instance a flex row yes
there we go let's say that inside my
sidebar okay I would have another div
which is a sidebar and down there I
would have a menu
all right what I have in this complex in
this complex element a sidebar and a
menu basically on Flex color
without Flex so my parent there doesn't
get any Flex I got naturally a flex call
but sometimes you would need to specify
that you want to have a flex call so
basically what you're going to do is
exactly the same you're going to type
first flex then you're gonna add Flex
call because you want okay not on your
sidebar everything would be a colon all
right so there we go we've got it let's
get back to flex Direction and we see
that we can invert we can reverse the uh
the direction and this is why we are in
Flex Direction so I'm going to copy
paste Flex rule reverse and I'm going to
go there on the parent actually not the
parent there but the children that is
parent of main content and this sidebar
so I'm going to add here next to this
Flex row reverse and let's look what is
going to happen
when I get back what I have
is my two elements that have been
reversed
main content is supposed to be the first
div and finally it's a sidebar and menu
that appear as first it's because I've
used Flex row reverse okay and now let's
see if we remove the flex row that we
put before and the flex that is here and
I save and I get back
what happened is that nothing happens
anymore
nothing happens anymore I got my Flex
rule reverse but on my CSS down there we
can see that I got here a problem and
this problem says that we have to put
another
property to say what display do you want
to use so let's just try there it talks
about display block and if I put display
block
nothing happens
nothing happens because Flex Direction
actually
needs to get Flex as a property so what
you got to do is always to specify Flex
before you use a flex class after let's
remove this reverse properties that
we've got for now and let's get back on
our main element so here I get to remove
also my Flex and there we go this is
supposed to be my application with a
main content and a sidebar menu
but what I want to have is basically
I won't have space I want to have a big
main content and to do that what I can
do is to use flex grow
flexgro help us to make a a div where we
had the property Flex
at a certain size and if we look at the
example down there we've got group that
we can use on the colon we want to grow
and we've got also we see Flex none on
other columns so I need to add grow not
to my parent but to my main content
because this is my main content that I
want
to be grow so I'm going to get back and
there we go we see that my main content
take all the space and next my content
where I added Flex known take the size
he had to take let's talk now about Flex
basis so we can deal with column size
this way so what I'm going to do I'm
going to get back to my uh main content
that I'm going to add a class name and
I'm going to add basis and here I want
to have three of four of the size of the
screen and down there my class name of
course I want to have
of course one on four so I'm going to
save get back update and now there we go
we see that main content is going to
take three of four of the row size and
one on four for the sidebar and if I go
down it's exactly the same it is working
the same way but at the moment do
content of the sidebar will stick to the
size that we applied with flex bases so
there's a lot of example you can also
use the basis with a certain size
already determined by Tailwind it's
really useful and of course you can work
also on the hover and focus with that so
basically we would need that to apply
some sizes to some elements and if I
would have another sidebar so let's say
that we're gonna go there and put
another sidebar what I would do here is
that actually it would not work okay it
will not work exactly the way we want to
work what we would do instead is to put
two on Fourth okay
so if I put two on four I got here one
colon here main content will take two on
four and this one one on four and it can
go up to 12 so if we put 12 to every
value there I would say that here I
would have a 2 and here I would have for
instance A6 and 6 plus 2 it's 8 it
misses four so I can put four at there
when I get back and I update
there we go we have a size of four
applied here a size of six applying here
and the size of two applied here on 12.
so bases help us basically to deal with
the original size of every div on a row
and actually I want to invert I want to
put first my side mount then my main
content then I'm going to add to my
sidebar a width so I'm going to add the
width let's say 32 okay and what I want
to have there I want to have a width
full of my main content so I'm going to
get back there updating and there we go
I got my sidebar and my main content and
what I want to do actually
is that when I'm going to just go down
like this I want my main content to come
under my sidebar there all right so to
be more clear I'm going to add some
color I'm going to add a BG red 600 to
my main content okay so when I update
there we go I get the red part and then
I'm going to add a BG Sky of 500 to my
sidebar
all right there we go so we've got these
two elements there and what I want to do
I want to change the flex properties
when I arrive on a certain size so how
could I do this
how could I do this let's get back to
the documentation and let's get back to
the flex zero Direction
so when I get back on there here we see
that what I can do is to add for
instance let's add these Flex Flex
column and on MD Flex rule
I go there and on my parent I had Flex
Flex call what's happening is that I'm
on a roll but if I go down suddenly I
have a mobile Behavior okay I got a
mobile behavior and my sidebar doesn't
take the whole Space so I can do
actually exactly the same I can put my
medium on the size of the sidebar so
basically here what we've got is that
Myspace is automatically fulfilled okay
so this is how we can work actually with
flex Direction depending on the screen
size that you have so on a mobile you
would have a different behavior and
Tailwind is very useful for that okay
terwin is very easy to deal with for
instance you have got also the flex wrap
properties that helps you to basically
wrap or not your content let's take this
example there so I'm going to copy paste
this and get back I'm going to go
directly on this row so basically I'm
going to remove what I did
okay I'm going to put this there we go
and I'm going to put class name so I got
my elements there okay one two three and
let's say that I want them all of them
to be
so basically we work with what we've
learned with full or grow
and what's going to happen is that it's
not taking all the size because I have
to specify a wasteful and there we go so
I got my elements there so I got my
three columns there and we see that they
don't wrap wrap it means that you want
the element to go automatically on a new
row at the line actually and if I had
several other elements okay so four or
five there we go we see that we stay on
a rule we stay on the same rule on the
opposite what we can use is wrap so we
used flex no wrap until now now I'm
going to use flex wrap and what is going
to happen is that every every column is
on wistful so they all go to the line
because they take all the space but
instead of having a wistful let's say
that they have a property of 32 okay and
with 32 we see that automatically we go
to the line because we added a flex wrap
property so with wrap you can go
directly to the line and of course
exactly like Flex column you get Flex
wrap reverse if you want to invert and
you can of course use them with the
media queries properties let's talk
about now the justify content property
sometimes you have elements like this
and you want to justify them in a
specific place
and very often you want to justify them
in the center as we see there what we
can do is to use justify Center so there
I came back I have my sidebar and my
main content with no property okay so
let's say that up there on the flex
parent I want to specify that they
justify on the center I want to have my
sidebar and my main content div on the
center okay I don't want to have them on
the left I don't want to have them on
the right I want to have them on the
center
so I'm going to save I'm going to update
and there we go we see that I got my
content now on the center actually this
is not really what I want to have what I
want to have actually is to have a
justify start start it means on the
beginning of the row so on the left
start is for the left
so basically I have the initial state so
I can remove basically this justify all
right but let's say that now I want to
justify on the right so now I need to
specify I need to specify that I want to
justify and this one is going to be end
and is for the right and when I save
okay and I update
suddenly my content is on the right so
you use justify content all right you
use justify content to specify where you
want this element to be but there is
another one which is interesting
it's Justified between so space between
with space between and justify between
actually
you can say that you want that there is
equal space between elements and so if I
type justify between here and I save
okay we see that my sidebar okay is on
the left and my main content is on the
right why because those two columns they
got actually they got actually the same
size I mean they are automatically on
the content size and we want they
created space between it okay justify
between created space between those two
elements and sometimes it's very useful
we want to create an equal space between
elements if I had a new colon let's say
another sidebar okay another sidebar
what is going to happen is that there
will be equal space between those three
elements so when I get back there we go
finally you get Space evenly and let's
look at the definition of space evenly
use justify evenly to justify item along
the container's main axis
such that there is an equal space amount
around each item evenly
and there we go there is an equal space
created between all these elements for
flexbox we use also align items we saw
that on a row we want to deal with the
space between elements and how to order
them but actually now on the vertical
how we do actually on the vertical we
use align items so here I got align
items and here I got a justify evenly so
let's say that on my main content I will
add an H1 so main content and P here I'm
going to add some lorem ipsum so I'm
going to type lorem ipsum there we go so
I get some text there and there we go we
see that actually
what's happening is that all the content
is aligned on the top so when there is
text on the sidebar it starts on the top
okay and Main content starts on the top
and another sidebar starts on the top
and here it's wrapping
so here what I could do with flex
property
is to actually okay use item start and
we got the same example there one two
three everything is aligned on the top
so I use item start to align on the top
but here it makes no sense because it's
already by default I lean on the top
let's say that now we want to align
everything on the center so if I put
items Center instead of start and
suddenly we see that sidebar is on the
center and another sidebar on the on the
right is also on the center everything
is aligned on the center and it is based
on the size of the highest content
Division and the highest content
division there it's actually this one we
see that we have 96 pixels of 8 and the
sidebar is 24 so it calculates actually
how to align in the center those two
elements and it's the same for the other
one there on the right for the sidebar
we are 48 it calculates automatically to
align on the center of course you
understand now that to align on the end
we can put e times n and when I update
so now on the bottom we've got
everything aligned with item end another
example may be a bit more tricky we can
copy paste this it's the Baseline so the
Baseline it's based based on the line
that starts inside your div so I'm going
to copy paste this I'm going to get back
and for now we've got this example
what I'm going to do is to just remove
all of this and put the official example
and instead of class I'm going to add
class name and there we go okay
so when I update
there we see that I get some elements
and to put more
um space I'm going to add a BG Sky 500
to the first one then I'm going to add a
BG red 500 to this one and I'm going to
add a BG green 500 to the third one so I
got some padding that is applied and I
got e-time Baseline there put as a class
on my div so when I get back and I
update
we see that what's happening with item
Baseline is that we align everything on
actually basically do content and the
Baseline of the content it's one two
three but our divs they have padding so
they have a different hate or different
they can have also a different width but
here they have a different eight we see
that even they have a different eight
and they don't start on the first line
here on the top or on the center or on
the bottom What's Happening Here with
item Baseline we based all our div on
the Baseline
tailoring CSS is providing to us grids
and with grades we can create columns
exactly like Flex but in another way
actually when designers are developing
the templates most of the time they are
using grids to separate elements from
each other
on flexbox we have the possibility to
put elements next to each other however
grids help us to create Dynamic leader
columns we need so down there we've got
an example okay of grids that we can
create let's say that we have a list of
element and we want to display them next
to each other this way what we can use
is grid so back in my application there
I'm going to create actually a grid
there and what I'm gonna do I'm going to
remove this title and there we go so
down there I'm going to type grid okay
and then I'm going to type grid calls
and there I need to put a number
and basically uh on those grids you get
maximum 12 columns okay
so what we want to have we want to have
a maximum four columns there so I'm
going to Type 4 and there we go so now
what I can do is directly to say Okay I
want to have for instance a First Column
with an element all right so first
element then I want to have this colon
actually
I want it to be
um let's give it a background okay
so I'm going to say that I want to have
BG Sky 500 all right and I want to have
some padding so I'm going to put PX
um well actually we don't need to put a
padding there we go yeah let's let's put
the padding okay we're gonna put padding
six okay and we want to be a little bit
rounded okay so I'm going to put yes
rounded LG there we go and let's say
that now I want to have a second element
which will be and actually it's not
element it's supposed to be columns okay
columns there we go
and now if I get back to my app
there what I have is those two colon
next to each other all right but we said
before there with grid codes that we
want to have a four uh actually Four
columns and right now we only have two
so let's put a third column okay so
third column so I put an S but I should
remove it
actually there we go and Forest colon
there we go now we've got our four
columns there and exactly like we see in
the template there we've got the four
column at the same level
and what is cool
um with um this grid is that as you see
here I got several size that I can put
up to 12 okay and if I want to have
space between the colon what I can do is
to add a class called Gap so here I can
type Gap and if I put one you will see
that
a little space will be between the
element
so let's imagine that we would like to
create a blog with articles next next to
each other would be amazing to deal with
these with the colors okay so let's put
a gap four instead and there we go
so we've got
four columns there all right we've got
four columns
and actually let's try to put a fifth
column so instead of having this I'm
going to just put one okay then I'm
going to put two I'm going to put three
then I'm going to put four and then I'm
going to put five and let's say that
we're gonna have a six also what is
going to happen
well this is what is magical with grids
is that as you see it's wrapping
automatically on the line so we go on
the line and we continue to create as
much columns as we want but actually we
stay on this base of four now let's try
to put a base of three if I go on the
base of three and I update now I got
three columns all right I got now three
columns and if I put for instance 2
what I'm gonna have is two columns okay
so you understood now that we can deal
with columns this way with the number we
want and actually there are plenty of
options one two three four five six and
there we go this is how it works
of course now I'm on a desktop but if I
lower the size what's gonna happen well
actually my grids are going to stay the
same so what I want to do is to say that
on a certain size I want to have four so
I put LG onto on on the beginning of my
class well what I can do also is to say
hey
when I'm on a tab I want to pass to the
grid calls 2. I want them to be on two
on the size two so now what I'm gonna do
actually is to reduce the size and
what's gonna happen is that suddenly we
see that my element
are taking the place I want to so
basically it's going to take two columns
and there we go it's working and if I go
lower we even see that actually now
because I didn't provide any class so
I'm supposed to have this yeah before LG
there we go I didn't provide any class
okay
for the calls so it's going on the top
of each other okay so that's really cool
um great with columns I'm using them all
the time
um it's very very useful to create
templates with that
however sometimes we need to deal
with actually the size of our columns
and of course Tailwind thought about
this problem with grids by using the
call span okay class so as you see here
we can deal with the size of our colon
inside the grid and we've got a lot of
elements we can deal with
so what I'm proposing you to do is
actually okay actually to get back on
our model there and let's put instead of
four we're gonna put three and there we
go and let's say that what we want to
have actually is to have a bigger colon
okay for one element so let's say that
we want this four to take the two sides
of the the on third actually to take the
first two columns what we can do is to
use call span 2 for instance here and
because here we see that we have three
columns we are saying two uh the the
this column to take actually two sizes
so it's the number four and what I'm
gonna do is to go on the number four and
I'm going to add my class there so I'm
going to type call span okay and here
I'm going to put two I'm gonna say that
I want the this fourth column to take
the two columns so I'm going to update
and look at that and there we go uh
first colon and we can change the color
to see it clearly I'm going to do BG red
500 okay I need to update as we see now
we've got this element that is taking
two columns and if I put a call span
free
and I update
my colon is suddenly taking the three
colors okay it's like a row suddenly
because I took the maximum which is
specified up there I want to use grid
cores free what's happening if I'm
putting a 4 for instance so I'm going to
update well actually if you put four
it's not gonna work because the maximum
that you can have is the parent class
definition that we have here and let's
take for instance a 12 and we will see
that it will be actually the same
problem it's creating something that we
don't want to happen okay it's dirty
actually what we want to do if we want
to have 12 it it's to put 12 on the
parent so when I get back and I update
there we go we see that this colon is
actually taking 12 colons there and
that's what we supposed to do because we
wrote the code in in this way but on the
first row now we see that there's only
three columns actually on the 12 we
could have had so it's not necessarily a
very good example and a very well
designed but there we go that's what you
can do with the grid calls and we if we
update that we will have empty spaces
sometimes in your Design This is what
you want to happen this is how it can
work and of course if we go down what we
can see is that we can move
some elements to say you have to start
there or you have to start there it's
working with core start and call end
so what I'm proposing you to to do is to
take this example okay exactly the
example that we had there
and I'm going to get back I'm going to
remove this okay so there I'm going to
put my example and instead of having
this I'm going to put again my BG Sky
500 and instead of class I'm going to
have class name all right if I get back
to my example so I'm going to add a bit
of more space like I did before so I'm
going to have a padding six there we go
and what I want to add also is a rounded
LG so I'm going to put rounded LG to add
some a bit of design there we go so we
see that we have a First Column zero one
and we will need to take four space four
space on six
so basically it's supposed to start
actually at one here it's supposed to be
the First Column but we specify with
cold start that we want it to start on
the second column and the second column
is supposed to start here because we're
supposed to have six colors before okay
so if I put call start free what's gonna
happen is that my element is going to
start on the third column all right
and if we go further what we could say
is to say well actually
here my second column there I wanted to
start on one okay but I will need to
stop on free and as we see it's taking
actually do it first took colon It's
stopping on free if I put a 4 call n
four what's gonna happen is that now my
colon is going to end on four so if you
want to deal with design actually what
you can do is to use call start and call
hand depending on the size of the colon
you already Define before talking about
the size of the colon sometimes we want
the size to be automatically display on
its content and sometimes we don't want
necessary to have a specific size of the
grid
in short we don't want to use this
system of 12 colon what you can do is to
use actually
Auto call Max all right so basically
here I got an example I got my grid
and I got a grid flow call that we are
going to see just after
and what's happening there is that I
didn't specify any size in my columns
but I specify that I want them to deal
with the content they have okay so
basically grid calls Max gives a result
like this we still have the grid system
however it's depending on the size of
its content okay it's exactly like Flex
actually but it helps you to deal with
the automatical size okay so this is how
you would deal with that and you can if
you want customize
these grid Auto colons exactly inside
your Tailwind config.js okay so grid
Auto colon helps you to deal with the
size automatically of the content of the
colon we've talked about the columns
with grid now let's talk about the rows
because yes we have grid codes one two
three four five until 12 but we also
have grid rows of course you understood
that now grid rows is used to display in
columns are element
so it's working exactly the same as
columns however it goes to maximum six
okay so we got grid row 6 as a maximum
value and here we get an example all our
rows all right
are displayed like this one two three
four five six seven eight and to do that
we use actually okay we use grid rows so
here I got a list of divs that I want to
display too and what I'm gonna do is to
add green grid flow code grid rows for
and GAP four all those elements are
supposed to be display in a grid so from
the left to the right but actually now
with grid rows it's going to be
displayed from the top to the bottom so
I'm gonna get back and I'm going to
update and suddenly
one two three four five six are
displayed vertically all right so what
where is actually the size of the
elements we are dealing with
grid rows four here okay we get the
example there
grid Rows 4 is dealing with the number
of elements in the colon so when you
reach number four it switched to the
other column
so what I can do is actually adding
several other elements
nine
ten eleven and let's say 12 and let's
see what is going to happen
what is going to happen is that it's
going to continue
okay to create columns and it's going to
stay on the basis of four elements
if I put here for instance grid row 6
went too fast grid row 6 there we go
what's gonna happen is that it's going
to switch at the number six and then
it's going to pass to another element if
you want to use rows with Grid it's
totally possible the difference is that
it's going to switch on the number of
elements on your colon and it's going to
switch to the next column you understood
now that we can also work with stop and
n as we did with colon we can actually
say that the first element
is going to take some space so let's get
back there and let's put 4 again so we
get there we go we'll get our column
this way let's say let's say that we
want to have the first element
uh taking a specific space so actually
we're gonna take two space okay so I
will need to take two rows so I'm going
to go there and on the first element I'm
going to put row span 2. all right and
what's gonna happen now it's that there
we go my first element
took two rows and if I put Rose pen
three it's going to take three rows okay
and let's go on The Fifth Element and
let's add also rows pattern free
let's look at it there we go we see that
five took free space however it's
creating empty space there it's totally
normal the number five cannot fit into
three rows because we are limited to
four and if we put the number five there
it would make actually one two and three
rows so five rows it's not working
anymore so actually we were supposed to
put here instead of uh three rows rows
band two and there we go it's fitting
our content it's also exactly the same
with raw raw end and if I wanted to make
complicated stuff such as different rows
on different lines etc for design
purpose I could do it here is maybe the
most interesting part about Grid it's
the autoflow and it's exactly the same
for columns we can say actually to our
grid to place elements automatically and
not to deal with those space that we got
so down there we've got an example
actually and here we've got our setup
already done there is no grid plus
placed yet and what we would like to do
is that our element okay will deal
automatically with the size so they will
be placed at the right place four we
don't get any
um any kind of space empty space in our
grid alright
so what we can do we can use grid so
first let's put grid
and then we can use grid flow row dance
okay so I'm going to type grid flow row
Dance all right and just this let's look
if it's some things gonna change nothing
is changing in my template all right so
what I want to do now is to add three
columns and actually grid rows free all
right this is the basis we want we want
to give so we give three columns so it
suppose to switch on three columns then
maximum free rows
okay let's look at the results
and there we go so we're going to add
some Gap we do type Gap four all right
let's add call span 2 to My First Column
and when I get back it's taking the two
places all right
but now if I put correspond to on this
one I'm gonna have an empty space as I
showed you before
not in this case because I put grid flow
row dance so I'm going to type call span
2 I'm going to say
and what's gonna happen and which is
magical
it's that now we are dealing with empty
space
and here we've got the column one and
column two that get the same size that
came on the top and Tailwind fulfill the
space that we got there three four seven
etc etc now I want to test something
else I want to say that for instance the
current 6
called span two would have also
a space of two
what's gonna happen is that the number
five stays at this place and the number
six took all the space so it's also
working on the right side okay it's also
working on the right side let's put now
for instance the number 10 on call span
2.
all right I'm gonna say and there we go
so it's really cool because it's
fulfilling automatically okay my empty
space so grid is very very useful and
actually you will use grid all the time
when you start to code with Tailwind
however you have to understand what are
colons what are rows how to display the
sizes but also what you need to deal
with is the autoflow of your element and
then we've got a good example on how we
can fulfill empty spaces because this is
what you're gonna have most of the time
as a problem on flex and Grid it's empty
spaces you can deal with that with
autoflow
layouts with Tailwind are very easy to
handle with and the first thing we got
to learn about layout is container you
may have seen me using container a lot
in the previous lesson but we never
really focused on it so let's go so on
the official documentation we can see
that first
we can use a class that is called
container all right and we see that
there are break points and through those
breakpoints we we are adding properties
to our container that change its current
size all right so right now I don't get
any container I just got a parental div
and what I'm going to do I'm just going
to create a container and inside I'm
going to put an H1 which will be
actually hello yeah there we go once
it's done what we can do is to add a
background red 500 because we want to
see where our container is and what size
does it take so when I get back to my
app and I update there we go we see that
we have this red rectangle which is
actually the proportions of our
container
so if I open my inspector and I pass my
mouth on it we see that the size is 7
768 and the thing is that right now I am
zoomed so if I zoom out there we go and
I pass my mouth it's a
1536 and if I go there to find my
proportion my property we see that
536 it's the value of the two Excel size
all right and we see that here on the
size is it's decreasing so we pass to
100
1280 pixels
124
768
640 pixels etc etc and we see that those
breakpoints are related to the basic
breakpoints of Tailwind all right so if
I zoom out
and I go there and what I'm gonna do is
looking at the size of this element
I'm going to just
um lower the size of my screen all right
so I'm going to do this quickly little
by little and we will see that suddenly
my red rectangle is losing its width
okay and what's happening there it's
really easy to understand
is that with the media queries we are
switching actually sizes okay and
actually right now we are on
668 pixel down there exactly what was
written there on the medium size exactly
here okay so container is helping us to
deal actually with the size of actually
our element when we want to put contact
however the thing is that right now
it's not centered
and we would like to be centered and if
we go to the documentation we see that
we can center with MX Auto so what I'm
gonna do I'm going to add MX Auto and
suddenly is going to be on the center
there we go and if I lower the size
again it's going to work again and we
suddenly understand
that this container lets space on the
size okay on the side sorry here you see
on the side I got space and if I lower
it again and again I need to reach I
think 640 pixels there we go
two don't have any padding anymore or
margin and the thing is that with um
with containers it's adapting itself
automatically to the size of the desktop
and this is what we want to do
however you will see that often when you
will use container you will be obliged
to add a mix Auto if you don't want to
do this
we can go directly inside our
terrain.config.js so first I'm going to
remove it okay I'm going to remove this
mx02 there we go and we see that here on
container Center true I can
automatically Center my container okay
so now I'm gonna go on terwin.config.js
and here on my team what I can do is put
container Center through so it's
supposed to Center my container
automatically and we see now that it is
working a last thing with container is
that as you see here
I'm going to have content that that will
stick actually that will stick to my
border and I often don't want to do that
the best thing to do for me is to always
add some padding a little bit of padding
okay and there we go we see that we got
space that is put inside the container
it's always better because on the mobile
after you will have some space that you
don't want so it's just a tips that I
give you now always deal and always
remember with the padding inside the
container if you don't want your content
to be appearing
um to the to the Border actually with
tailoring layouts we can deal with
columns for instance we want to create
several colons with different elements
we can simply use the class columns
minus one two three four five until 12.
or we can deal also with sizes of the
colon so there are already sizes that
are done and this is the result so let's
say that
here I'm gonna have a first paragraph
with one row M ipsu then I will have
another one actually there we go and
then I will have another one again okay
so I got these three paragraph and when
I get back there we go I'm there so I'm
going to remove this BG red 500 that is
useless for now there we go
and if I use for instance colon 3
because I got three elements let's try
it in there columns three I'm going to
save I'm going to update there we go
suddenly my content is on three columns
but what happened if I put a
fourth colon all right and I save
well actually and we don't see it we
don't see where it is actually it
doesn't change anything because all your
content is going to be fulfilled on
three different colon okay so if I just
copy this
okay and I had it there it's going to
continue and all the content will be
displayed on three columns okay let's
say that now I want to have two columns
and suddenly I will have two columns
let's say that I want to have 12 columns
it will be weird there we go we've got
our content on 12 columns okay so this
is how it works however if you want to
have for instance a specific size let's
say that we want to have a small colon
of five colons LG let's take it we need
to get back there I'm going to use
Colon's LG what's going to happen is
that the size of the colon that will be
display will be automatically LG so 500
or something
and what we like is that it's
automatically responsive so this is how
you would use colon but let's try now
with an image so I'm going to copy this
image there and let's say that I'm going
to add an image and it's going to be
this one and when I'm going to save
there we go then you see that the image
is taking the whole size and the text is
on the right all right which is cool is
that and we get the example there
depending on the elements that you got
and depending on the size okay it's
going to adapt itself automatically and
that's something that we want when we
are dealing with canons let's talk now
about the display we often use the
display with terrain CSS Okay so we've
got basically
do a basic display that we can have in
CSS so for Block we have display block
for inline block we have inline block
etc etc and we also have Flex we already
saw Flex in this course so previously
you can check out the flex listen it's
just putting display Flex inline Flex
table table caption
etc etc and if you want to also deal
with the display on the table table cell
Etc it's happening in there and which is
cool which you would use often
I think personally
um you would need often to hide some
element so let's say that we have our
image there okay so I'm going to type
class name hidden
suddenly okay my element has been hidden
okay and if I want to block it again
there we go it appears there all right
so what you can use also is inline block
you would all often use inline or inline
block okay and there you get some
example or you would have for instance
block as an element that you could use
okay the floats we got very good example
there we can see that we can make float
an image on the left on the right or
float known to have it on the top let's
get back to our example I removed our
colon and we got this big image and it's
just crazy for us okay give a width to
this image so it's going to be with 64.
I think it's going to be yes there we go
if I want to have my image to float on
the left okay what I can simply type is
float left all right so now it's
Suddenly It's going to stick to the text
and Float right there we go we're gonna
have the image on the right okay good
and we have another one which is float
known and it happens often that you
don't want to have this dirt text next
to your image so you will type float
known and actually it's exactly the same
as as if there is no float clear is here
to control the wrapping of content
around an element
so let's just copy paste this image
there and let's give it a new size let's
say uh let's say 42 32 sorry so I'm
going to update and suddenly I get to
image there okay so what I'm going to do
is that I'm going to put a float left
okay to this image and a float right to
this one all right what's gonna happen
now is that we got the image okay on the
left and on the right and if I put a
clear left to my text so let's first try
here
class name
there we go clear left
and I'm saving what's happening is that
my text is going to be set
on the size of the image on the left all
right but if I put clear right
and I update it's going to be set under
the image of the right side okay so here
we understand that we are setting the
text line or the content line actually
to the image on the right or on the left
and if I use
clear both okay what's going to happen
is that it's going to be set on the line
of the highest element all right you've
got several other options Canon of
course and Canon it's exactly like if
you didn't do anything okay so I update
and there we go position is a real
subject when you want to learn CSS and
with taiwin it's really easy to handle
alright so we see that here we've got an
absolute class which gives us position
absolute and we get a relative which
give us a position relative all right
so let's say that at first we would have
a parrot so inside our container I'm
going to create a parent with a relative
position it will be BG red 500 we're
gonna give a bit of rounded and a bit of
sizing and it's going to be pixel 8. and
there we go so what's gonna happen in
there I'm going to add some eight and
I'm going to add some weight eight and
wait there we go and when I go back I
suddenly have this Square red all right
and let's say that inside I would have
almost the same
okay let's say I would have a div with a
width maybe more little yes
h24 and then dot BG uh green
500 rounded LG I say when I get back I
got this green square inside the red one
okay and what I can do actually we see
we get some example
I can give actually the relative
position to my parent which will say
that every element under will be
relative to this one
and suddenly if I put absolute as a
class to my div here
and I get back and I update nothing will
change however however what I can do now
with this absolute position is to work
on the top right left or bottom okay and
which is cool there is that I get plenty
of classes that help me to deal actually
with top bottom etc etc and exactly like
padding and merging I can work on the
position that I want so I want this
green square to be on the top instead of
bottom
what I can do now is next to Absolute to
put top zero so if I save that and I get
back okay and I update
suddenly my square is on the top zero
all right and if I want to put on the
left 0 I can also do it so when I say
there we go it's moving on the left
because I said to him that each parent
is this one the relative one and the
children has an absolute property and
the top zero NLF zero which means that
he has to relate to the top zero and the
left zero of the relative all right
so let's say that I want now
that
um for instance
I want now to be outside of the square
okay I want this green one to be outside
can I do this
let's say that I want to do minus top 2.
what's gonna happen there I'm going to
update
and we see that my square is going we
don't see it exactly but we see that my
Square
is not rounded there which means that
I'm outside of the red square and let's
say that I want to do the same I can do
minus for a negative value left two
okay
so I have to remove this left zero that
I have there all right
and when I update
there we go we see that my element came
out
so with the property top right bottom
left and there are plenty of element
that you can do so let's say that we can
use this inset property so we get we saw
top bottom left okay it's working easy
it's really easy to understand
let's try this inset so I'm going to
remove my
negative property so I'm going to type
inset 2. when I get back and I update we
see that it's like a padding it
automatically went
on a special position
because of insight let's look at the
fixed property inside our application so
here we get a very good example we got a
parent that is relative okay with the
fixed property as a children and we see
down there that we can actually scroll
inside okay inside our box and contact
stay fixed it stay fixed on the bottom
so most of the time this is the position
that you will use if you want to have a
sticky or a fixed element now let's talk
about the Overflow we can deal with
overflow with several classes Auto Eden
scroll when you want to scroll inside an
element and if you want to show or not
an element you can deal with that so
let's look at the example there we've
got an overflow visible and we've got an
image inside a box that have a certain
size
so this box there have a certain size
okay and actually the image as you see
is going out of the box with overflow
visible the image is authorized to go
out of the box however with overflow
Eden we want that the Box will be the
actual limits okay we want the box to be
the limit of the content and we don't
want to have content that goes outside
so we will use overflow Eden to hide the
content from outside and we can go
further and what we can do is to say we
want to have an overflow Auto so for the
example now I've created a lot of text
really really big and as you see
by Nature the browser allows you to be
on overflow Auto so when you want to
scroll into a div what you need to put
is this overflow Auto and if you are not
able just add the property okay we've
got another example which is cool here
is that sometimes you want to scroll
from the left to the right you can use
overflow X Auto to do it and vertically
you can use also overflow y Auto to do
it
for the visibility it's almost the same
as display known or not however the
thing is that here
what's happening is that it's invisible
so let's just guys let's just copy paste
this example so I'm gonna go back there
and what I'm gonna do I'm going to
remove all of this I'm going to create a
new container there we go and I'm going
to add this so I'm going to add class
name
there we go and I want to add some color
there so I'm going to add a class name
bgt 500 and I'm going to copy paste this
one and there we go so we see that our
second element as an invisible class
which is number two
and when I get back and I update there
we go so we got one we got three so
finally I'm going to get back to to this
age screen because I think it's better
for our example there we go we see that
one is visible two is invisible and
three is visible so let's look at the
CSS and the thing is that right now
invisible
okay as a visibility Eden so I'm going
to move there and just yet here just
down there you see that it's visibility
Eden all right
so you can use visibility this way when
you want to show or hide content the
difference with display hidden or not is
that it's also appearing in your HTML
but now it's invisible or not
finally let's talk about the Z index
with Z index you can put several
elements on top of each other
so let's get back again on this example
so here I'm going to remove this all
right and instead of the classes here
I'm going to put class name there we go
and I'm going to add a BG red 500 there
we go we see here that we've got
actually
z40 z30 z20 Z10 okay and what's going to
happen is that they are going to be on
the top of each other depending on their
size so here it's not really happening
what we should do is to say that we want
to have a flex there so it's supposed to
be there we go and let's gonna add some
sizes to these runs because it's a bit
tricky rounded LG border border yes
there we go border white okay and we're
supposed to have something that looks a
bit the same okay no it's not rounded LG
is rounded full
there we go round it full
there we go Jack position we use it to
control the position on an element
within its container okay so here what
we see is that we have an image with a
special size so let's try to do exactly
the same so I got my image
there which is really big right now
and what I want to do I want to reduce
its size so I'm going to add exactly
what they did so maybe it's a bit too
much I'm going to put
62. there we go 62 no 62 doesn't exist
sorry 64.
there we go 64. all right so now what
I'm going to do is that I got my square
and I got this object non-property so if
I add this object on property let's see
what's going to happen
actually here there we go we see that
the image has been centered inside my
Square
and from this moment what I can do
is and we pass the mouse here we see
that the position of our image actually
what we have basically it's object
Center here right now we get object
Center inside the div and when I just
look at it we see that I got my Square
let's say that now I want it to be on
the top what I can do is just using
object top so I'm going to get back
there I'm going to put object top
and when I update suddenly it's moving
okay it's moving we are on the top of
our image we don't see it clearly there
but let's say that I want to have an
object left
I can deal with the position of the
image inside my box and that's something
really useful sometimes when you want to
deal with the position of your image you
can use all those classes let's say that
now I want to have an object right
button I can deal with that so I'm going
to put object right button and I'm going
to save get back update and suddenly
there we go I finish there okay so
object position is really really useful
when you want to deal with the position
of your image inside your element inside
your Square Edition layout there are
several elements that I didn't present
it to you because I think they are
useful but you can really understand
yourself by reading the documentation
you get break after that helps you to
break after an element break before to
break before break inside you get also
the Box decoration break okay so here
you see that you can create some
decoration and you want this decoration
to break or not
you got box sizing to be honest I don't
use it that much
but you can deal with actually how the
browser should calculate an element
total size all right and what you have
also it's the over scroll Behavior we
talked about it a bit with our overflow
Eden it's all you want to deal with the
over scroll
here I get a header
and what I'm gonna do I'm just going to
add the class border and what's gonna
happen now it's that around my header I
will have a border of one pixel all
around my header okay
if I want to deal with the width of this
border I can add a size and of course
like always with here in CSS we can add
a number to specify the size okay so
here I'm going just to add two and when
I get back and I update we see that my
border is thicker and I can go up to uh
8 or 12 I don't remember but if you go
on the official documentation you will
see that we can have really thick border
okay what we can do also is to add
border on the left or border on the
right okay
so there what we have is that we can
pass actually top right bottom left
directly to our border class so let's
try now to just put a border bottom
element and what's gonna happen there is
that we have the regular header that we
would like to have so basically here we
have actually the border on the bottom
and if I had some padding on the top and
bottom let's say four okay py4 suddenly
there we go we've got our Adder so I'm
going to unzoom a little bit because I
was zooming there and there we go we see
that border and our border down is like
this let's say that now I want to add
actually a border um on the left
and I want it to be a border on the left
I want it to be thicker as eight I'm
going to say
here what we see that suddenly we've got
actually
a thicker border on the left that has
been pushed and let's say that on the
top we would like to have a border top
of four what's gonna happen is that on
top I'm gonna have a border top of four
the same for the right you understood
actually we could add borders like this
very very easily so down there we've got
a parent division with three elements
there and when I update we see that
with the Divide y class and divide color
so let's put a red instead and not a 200
but 500 we can see that between my
elements I have now a division okay and
this is really cool because if I add one
you will see
I will not be obliged to deal with both
the top but the bottom between elements
I can use divide like this I have now a
basic input type text and what I want to
do I want to basically add a specific
border to it and I want it to be colored
so if I go on Border color as I see
there I have an example I can specify
the color of my border specifically by
passing the color after border so here I
got my border 2 and Border rows 600 on
my input and when I get back
there we go there we see that so I'm
going to put the outline non class to
not see the outline blue that we see
there we go now we see that my border is
actually okay my border is actually uh
Rose okay so I passed the class it's
really easy to see so here you got all
the colors of course provided by 10 win
to pass your color for the Border style
it's exactly the same what you want to
do is here to put for instance a border
dashed okay and suddenly we've got the
effect of a border dashed there we go
otherwise you have the butter dotted so
if you put butter dotted you will have
actually the Border dotted okay all
right it can be useful sometimes you
never know or you can have the Border
double if I update there we go we've got
the butter double okay with border style
also you can specify border known there
we go if you don't want to have a border
this is how you deal with border Styles
remember the Divide you can specify the
width of your device so here we got
three elements and we say to them divide
on X so basically I copy pasted G
element there so I'm going to update and
there we go so we've got the Divide
there and what's gonna happen is that we
can say also that we want to reverse
Flex call reverse here and reverse do
divide also it's also working with the
Divide width but we can also work with
the Divide color so for instance we can
put a divide
so here I'm going to work on divide red
500 okay and suddenly we got a divide
color that changed for the Divide style
you understood it's exactly the same as
the border so let's put a divide dashed
which is very useful there we go divide
Dash so working with this tight color
and width of dividing it's exactly the
same as the Border instead you are using
divide as a first class I showed you
before that we can remove the outline
however if you want to have outline we
can also use as you see there the
outline Class 2 had an outline to an
element so I'm going just to copy paste
this element there and there we go so
here I got my button C and with outline
outline offset and outline four and now
you understood that outline four is for
the size of the outline and the offset
is for the space between the element and
the outline so there we go we got
something not really nice there but we
see that we've got some kind like a
border but it's creating actually an
outline if you don't want to have an
outline you can use outline known and
it's working of course exactly the same
if you want to change the color you can
pass outline the color and the weight of
the color and then suddenly it's
changing your color for the style you
can use Dash you can use dot double
exactly and for the outline exactly the
same finally let's talk about rings and
rings are creating actually box Shadow
around our elements okay so here I got
some examples okay of ring four let's
take this one and let's see what's gonna
happen if I put actually ring offset and
ring four so there in my class I'm going
to put ring offset and ring four okay so
I'm going to update and what's gonna
happen is that that around my button I'm
gonna have this kind of
box Shadow which is actually the ring
effect okay it's applying a solid box
shadow of a specific thickness to an
element so sometimes you want to focus
on element like this okay and you want
that we let a trace around it
this is actually what's happening in
there and actually those classes are
very useful if you really want to work
on the accessibility of your app you are
going to use all those classes and all
those elements provided by terrin to
improve this accessibility
if you want to use box Shadow or effects
or new elements with Tailwind CSS it's
possible here I got an application
running and I got a card and in this
card I got some text a button but the
thing is that this card is white on a
white background and I would like to
give some effects some perspective so
what can I do is to use a shadow and
here we see that we get classes that we
can use to have some Shadow okay so
let's try now with Shadow MD on my card
and what's gonna happen is that it's
going to have a shadow it gives a bit of
cons instance a bit of presence inside
my application okay that's really cool
but let's say that I would like to have
a bigger Shadow it's possible always
with Tailwind with the actually size
element that we can use so we got medium
but let's try with large
and we will see that suddenly we've got
a bit more Shadow and if we go down we
can see that we have several sizes
medium large Excel to excel that
actually create a specific Shadow
already determined by telwyn so if I use
two Excel Shadow there we go I will have
a bigger Shadow this way so it gives a
lot of consistency and it's really easy
to apply you use the class Shadow
alright however if you want to have some
Shadow inside what you can do is to use
the class Shadow inner so here it's not
necessarily the case okay
but as we see I've put some Shadow
inside my dip so it's not very visible
right now but yeah it's working and
sometimes if you don't want to have some
Shadow you can use the shadow known
class on an element and it's gonna
remove the current Shadow you added okay
what you can work also is on the color
of your Shadow which is really cool so
I'm going to get back and put a shadow
MD because I really liked the shadow MD
I think it's enough
uh too much Shadow it's a problem but
here it's better I'm gonna work with
that and I'm gonna add some colors so if
I go down there we see that we've got
some Shadow display let's say that I'm
going to add
and let's get back there and I already
use science so I'm going to add a shadow
cyan and let's say 500 I don't know if
it's going to give a nice effect it
doesn't but it's all right the
demonstration is here so we've got our
element there with the uh Shadow Scion
500. however what I want to do is to put
it instead on my button so I'm going to
use here a shadow MD and then the shadow
cyan 500 and I got a bit of effect
however
that's not really what I want I would
like to cut it so what I can do with
Tailwind is just to cut the color and
just add some opacity okay so here
opacity on 100 it's the normal color on
80 unless
etc etc you lower the opacity so here
I'm going to put half 50.
so that there we go and there we go
we've got a
like a shadow that is less aggressive
also what I want to add there is a text
white because on my button and there we
go we got something nicer in my opinion
okay so you can work with box Shadow
color this way so as I told you you can
work also with the opacity
of elements on Tailwind CSS and here
we've got the opacity of the elements so
which is very useful sometimes because
um what we would like to do is to say
yeah if this button is disabled I would
like to add some opacity okay it's
possible well we're going to try just
this if I put opacity 5 okay what's
going to happen is that my button is
going to almost disappear okay but it's
still clickable
be safe it's still clickable you will
have to deal with another class if you
want to disable it okay
so basically here as we saw we put 50 of
the cyan background Shadow there uh
actually if we put opacity 50 it's
exactly the same what's gonna happen is
that my button is going to be on opacity
50. I would do that if I would like to
disable my component okay so opacity is
really useful we can also put opacity on
every element made by 10. I'm going to
pass real quick on the mix blend mode
because I personally didn't use it a lot
in my Tailwind CSS experience but you
can control how elements should blend
with background okay so as you see you
can mix two elements and it will mix the
colors automatically this is how it
works with mix blend mode and you can
also work with the background blend mode
with actually
it helps you to deal with the color etc
etc it can be useful I have to admit
that for me I never had to use it it can
be useless but if you look for it it's
in the effect column there let's talk
now about the filters and filters are
very very useful because they help you
to deal with images and you're not
obliged to send back the image to
photoshop or just to call your graphics
or designer to change the image you can
use Tailwind to do it so let's talk
about the blur so here in my example
I've got a call like it's a card for
blog and we would have an image there
that I picked up on unsplash and what
I'm gonna do I'm going to blur this
image and as we see terrain provide to
us a burr class that I can use so what
I'm gonna do I'm going to take the blur
SM on the image there so I'm going to
get back and I'm going to add this blur
SM class to my email 8 and when I update
my image is finally blurred okay
so let's say that we would like to have
a higher bro we can use actually those
sizes that you know on telwyn CSS and
look at that there we go we've got the
blur to excel I'm going to give you uh
something really nice is that let's say
that the whole cut would be blurred on
two Excel there so it's a bit too much
actually what I'm going to do is just
use blur I'm going to update yeah I will
have this and let's say that when I pass
my mouse on it I want to remove the blur
so what I can do is use blur on so what
I'm going to do is hover and then blur
on okay I'm going to update and when I
pass my mouse it's going to remove the
blur oh nice it is you see I'm going to
remove the blur just on passing my mouse
there so you can use blur to blur your
images let's talk now about the
brightness so I'm going to remove this
blur stuff otherwise it will be
difficult I'm going to get back again
add my image there and let's say that I
want to work on the brightness I can use
brightness and the values comes from 0
to 200 okay so what I'm going to do
there I got the image I'm going to add
brightness 125 on the image and when I
update suddenly my image is brighter
okay so you can use brighter to improve
or to lower actually and let's try to
lower it let's put 50 instead
there we go I'm going to update and
finally my image is darker all right so
what's happen if I put it on my card
okay again
you see that the card is this color and
we can do exactly the same so let's just
put on Hover a brightness 100 okay
to see what's gonna happen and when I
pass my mouse on it there we go it
appears there so that's a nice effect
that we can use also sometimes we can
use the brightness
in contrary let's talk about the
contrast we can use also D contrast so
let's say that we're gonna have a
contrast and it's a bit different but it
looks like the same effect okay so
contrast 50 so I'm going to update okay
and there we go so we pass from Gray to
a normal contrasted
um car we have the filter drop shadow
that help us to drop some Shadow which
is basically the same as the shadow we
saw before we've got the grayscale so
grayscale can be really really useful so
let's try again let's put grayscale for
instance and suddenly we got our post in
in a grayscale but on hover if we want
to remove it we can put grayscale zero
so I'm going to put grayscale and zero
don't ask me why they didn't put
grayscale known we can also work with
you rotate filters so here we've got an
example and it comes from 0 to 180 we
are going to change actually
basically the color there so I'm going
to put Hue rotate 90 and suddenly we
change the color dynamically it can be
very useful we can also invert our image
so let's say that here I'm going to put
invert so the image or the card here I'm
taking both examples so it's really easy
for you to understand there we go we see
that we can invert so you got very good
example of this there to use actually
filters on a lot of elements in CSS you
can use also saturate it goes from 0 to
100 so let's put saturate and personally
I like saturate because sometimes
the images are not very well colored
okay they didn't pass by any uh Graphics
before and here we see suddenly we've
got more uh presence okay we got an
image that is brighter that the contrast
is very good and we've got this effect
that is really nice also we can use
sepia honestly I never use sepia but
let's say that if you had a very a very
old website a very whole style designs
website you could use this API on some
picture or if you want just to make
somebody holder and make an old picture
you could use sepia yeah there's a lot
of filters that you can use for the
photos sometimes you would need to put
some elements blurred but not blurred as
we see before
blurred inside this element so basically
you would use backdrop blur SM and here
we've got a an absolute
division inside our image that is
blurring a part of the image okay so we
get the image there and we get another
div that is a blurred there and it's
creating some blur it can be very very
useful when you want to make the image
appear but to blur some part okay and
you can work also on the brightness of
these divs you can work on the contrast
you can work on the grayscale on the U
rotate you understood you can irritate
all the filters before but on element on
top of each other through this backdrop
actually through this backdrop class
in CSS when you want to create an
animation or a transition you have to
write the class and Define it in your
key element
however with Tailwind CSS we got already
provided classes and it's always the
best to use to be honest and we can use
for instance transition
so here okay here I got an example when
I pass my mouse the button is moving up
and down okay and to do that I'm
supposed to write okay in CSS that on
Hover I want a transition is in out with
a delay and etc etc okay
so actually what I'm going to do first
is that I'm going to use the transform
translate basically we translate I can
move an element on the top on the right
on the left etc etc so what I want to do
is to use this minus translate okay so
that's what I'm going to type and
especially on the button so there when
I'm going to pass the button I want to
translate M okay
negatively so on the top by 50 okay
actually it's not 50 pixel I think it's
less okay so there we go our element has
moved to the top because I moved him
this way but it's too much what I want
to have it's like let's see when we pass
from zero okay when we are on zero it's
it's is initial position and if I type 1
suddenly okay it's moving up okay I want
to do it only on Hover so I'm typing
over
okay over translate y1 okay
and when I pass my mouse
it's moving only on Hover
and with translate we can move element
this way but however it's just terrible
like this what I would like to have is a
transition like this so what I can do is
to type simply simply
transition and you are going to use this
transition Class A lot of the time most
of the time because it's really easy
that with transition you just put a
regular delay I think it's maybe 200
milliseconds something like this we
gotta look at it but look now I put
transition what's gonna happen is that
it's smoother you know it's less violent
it doesn't pass from directly to bottom
minus two okay so let's look at this
transition class
and let's look at it and what's
happening there it's that there is a
duration basic of
150 milliseconds and we got the timing
function cubic busy okay that help us to
just say please uh be quiet so most of
the time you just have to use transition
to apply this
smooth changes okay but let's say that
now we want to change the delay we can
use the delay so I go on transition
delay and here I got many classes that
help me to deal with the delay of my
transition
so let's say I'm going to put the
highest delay which is delay
1000 okay so I'm going to go next to my
transition I'm going to delay 1000 okay
and when I get back I pass my mouse I'm
updating past my mouse and I have to
wait 1000 milliseconds so one second to
move okay and when I move out there we
go if I come back there we go if we go
way upper and we update
look at that bomb
bam this is how you can work with the
transition delay okay and you can work
also with the duration okay
how much time the duration is going to
uh work so let's add a duration 1000 so
duration 1000 it's a lot those examples
are just example for you if I pass my
mouse I will have to wait once one
second and I will have to wait one
second for the element to move again
again okay so duration for the duration
and for the delay delay easy to
understand
for the transition timing function it's
about to be the same you get the easing
entering okay is out and easy note okay
if you are familiar with that you can
use dynamically and directly the classes
if you are not familiar with easy note
easy not easy not is in and is out sorry
you can check Google made a very good
guide about it telwyn CSS is not the
best
4D animation there's not a lot of
Animation however there are the
animation that you need and for instance
you get the animation spin to make a
loader like this we often need loaders
like this
so what I'm going to do I'm going just
to add animation spin to my button which
is a bit dumb because I don't want my
button to turn like this but as you see
the animations pin is already applied to
it okay another animation that I can use
is animation ping and animation ping is
very cool however here we will we won't
need a button to get this animation also
but on the official documentation we got
a very good example we often need to do
notifications such as this one and we
would like to have something that glows
animation ping is really useful for that
also you get animate pearls and it's
working for what we call skeletons so
you can create these elements that you
see here and that's a good example for
the for the course as an exercise
you can create elements like this and
just add the pulse class it will create
this effect of opacity okay it comes
from white to more gray then comes back
to White Etc okay very very useful when
we go down we can also use the bounce
animation that make it jump so to that
you type animate bounce of course it's
always animate slash uh animate sorry
minus pulse minus bounce etc
etc and of course you can use that with
over also we often need to deal with the
scale of images and with Tailwind CSS we
can work with that with the scale class
so here we get example
we've got scale 100 which is the basic
scale of our image but let's say that we
would like to have a bigger scale so we
can use from 0 to 150 a bigger scale and
when I update suddenly my image is
bigger however as you see I'm eating
actually the text that is under so gotta
be careful all the time to deal with the
scale and let's say that I want to
reduce it I can also do it to 25 and
suddenly my image there is no 25 there
is 50 let's put 50 okay 50.
uh there we go there we go we've got a
lower sized image we see here that we
got to be careful always with the scale
because it can work
uh uh only if you deal with the content
next to it otherwise it will pass over
the content also we can rotate our
images and it goes from 0 to 180 degrees
of course so let's say that we would
like to have an image rotated of 90 so I
got to remove the scale that I have here
rotate 90 degrees what's going to happen
is that my image is going to rotate 90
degrees okay and now I'm here I'm going
to talk about the transform origin
um right now it's rotating on the center
of the image all right but if I change
the rotate origin and I put origin top
left okay so if I put there here origin
top left
is going to rotate from the top left
so it will be a total different okay uh
rotation okay and here it's not very
nice so I'm going to put
rotate 45 and what's going to happen
it's rotating you see
from the the the top so let's say that
now we're going to put a hover there and
we're gonna have some transition
and we will get the effect there so I'm
going to pass and when I pass on there
we see that our image is rotating so
it's a bit weird here because I have to
stay on the image but we see it's
rotating from the top the Transformer
origin help you to move
um the center of your image and where it
is rotating from so I can put for
instance origin bottom right okay let's
say that and when I'm going to get back
I'm going into update and pass my mouse
there we go we see that it's rotating
from the bottom right okay sometimes you
want to create effects it's really
really useful the translate effect we
already saw it with the button we can
use translate minus x minus 0 minus y
zero etc etc and for negative value it's
minus uh on on on the first before
translate and also what we can use is
translate on the columns for the
percentage age of your desktop so if you
want to translate
on the vertical at 25 or on the
horizontal at 75 you get all those
classes available there finally we can
use skew and with skew we can skew our
image so here we've got some example I'm
going to try to skew my image there so
I'm going to remove this or of this
transition there we go it's qy6 and
what's going to happen is that my image
has been skewed okay I can skew it way
more I think to 12 okay and I guess I
guess there we go I guess if I put a
minus on the front of it and I update
it's going to skew it on the other side
sometimes it can be useful so
Transitions and animations and transform
work together to help you to deal
quickly with a specific behavior of your
design or image
the best demonstration to show the power
of terrain CSS would be to create some
kind of custom design system
so I got several elements there a title
subtitle paragraph and call button here
I got an input text that we don't see
get a checkbox and a select there okay
and all of this is currently on my next
GS application
so I imported telwyn in my global.css
file and what's happening there is that
it's empty there is absolutely no Style
no size no color or nothing and I would
have to create everything from the
beginning so what we could do at first
is to add classes to these elements and
later we would move those classes into
custom classes inside our CSS okay that
could be an example
so let's start title subtitle and
paragraph should have three different
sizes so what I would do is to go there
and to add a first class name to my H1
and let's say that I would have a text
to excel all right then what I would do
also here is to put a text Excel to my
subtitle and to my paragraph I would
have a text base even though I know that
it's already on textbase we can see that
as a little difference between the sizes
but it's not very big actually what we
would like to have is a bigger
difference so I'm gonna get back and
what I'm gonna do I'm going to get up on
the size of the Excel so I'm going to
put free Excel because I really want to
have a difference between the subtitle
and the title and finally there we go we
see that there is a difference so what I
can do is just inspecting okay my first
element
and we see that the font size is
1.875 Ram okay and then the Excel is
1.25 RAM and on the paragraph is run Ram
so the other elements that we got done
they keep basically the same size okay
and right now I'm zooming just for this
course but on the regular size it's
going to be like this so we can see that
the paragraph the encode button will
have basically the same size we just
want to make a difference on the title
and subtitle so I'm going to zoom again
and there we go and what we would like
to have is a weight a different weight
for the title and subtitles in
comparison to the paragraph
so I would go to my documentation and I
will quick search there and I will type
wait
and here we see that I got font weight
so I'm going to click on that and I can
see that I got different type of weight
so I'm going to zoom and I got bold semi
bolt which could be cool so what I'm
going to do I'm going to get back and
here I'm going to add my font bold okay
and down there I'm going to add my font
semi bolt and I think this is what I
want to have all right so I'm gonna get
back and there we go I got a a title
with a phone bolt and a subtitle with a
font semi bolt okay the thing is now
what we would like to have there is some
space between everything is really stuck
so what I would do I would check for the
margin button
by default the H1 h2h3h4 they got margin
bottom with table in CSS everything is
reset from the start so here I'm gonna
add basically a margin button and I'm
going to start by mb2 okay I'm going to
save that it games on the beginning
and I'm going to update and we see that
suddenly I got space space that has been
created under my title all right I want
to have also a sub um actually a margin
but I mean on my subtitle so what I'm
going to do I'm going to do the same but
I'm not going to do mb2 because if I do
mb2 exactly like my main title I will
have a problem in my spaces okay I will
have a problem with this design system
later it will not make something nice
what I need to have is if I have a lower
font or a lower font size actually what
I would do is to lower exactly also the
margin button so I will put instead of
two I would put one and when I get back
yeah we we see that it's a bit better
all right so that's cool now if I unzoom
again and I see the result well I think
it could fit to a lot of blog posts that
we can read we get Space to breathe for
the elements all right
so the thing is now I'm writing all this
code there and if later for instance at
the end okay I would have another title
okay and I would save there this is
another title and I would have another
uh subtitle after that okay
the thing is though right now we don't
get the first margin top but it's
supposed to come from another piece of
content that we could put later the
thing is that I would have to copy paste
all the time my class name okay and
instead of doing that let's just say
that all rh1 will have these classes
okay we want to have all our H1 to get
these classes so what I can do I can go
back actually to my global.css file and
here I can select the current layer I'm
working on and this one is layer base
okay and inside this layer base actually
I would have all the HTML tags and all
the CSS classes that I'm going to create
or to use
to modify them
so let me give you an example right now
we are under HTML so here if I type
HTML and I open my curly brackets and I
put for instance like a color of red and
I'm saving and I get back to my app
suddenly the color red is applied to all
my HTML document the CSS
layer there has been applied on because
the sheet is imported inside my an xgs
application and I got my color red all
right
that's cool but now what I can do
actually I can say yeah my H1 it has to
get the these classes so I can go there
and type H1 and I could type of course
font weight
a bolt etc etc however
I can use apply apply from Tailwind help
me to import the classes so what I can
do is just taking this and I can import
them directly there so I'm going to put
that and there we go now what is going
to happen is that all H1 of my document
will have those class applied so to be
sure about that
to be sure about that I can remove
actually okay do class for my H1 up
there and I can remove it also down
there and we are supposed to keep the
same properties and it is working so if
I inspect my title there I've got the
margin bottom the font size the line a
the font weight that I'll apply from my
app underscore Global CSS sorry I gotta
move this there we go everything that
has been applied from my app global CSS
file all right so I'm going to get back
there I'm going to remove this HTML for
now because I'm not going to use it
yet so the difference now is I don't
need actually to specify that here
actually I want to add inline styles on
my HTML tag okay and I think I'm going
to do the same with H2 so I'm going to
copy paste this get back and I'm going
to say hey finally with H2 now I want to
apply those classes so I'm going to type
apply and I apply those classes all
right now I can remove this down there
and there we go of course if later you
will have several subtitles several
titles paragraph you would create
classes inside your HTML tag or you
could do the opposite creating that for
first the classes and then apply your
style and later it will apply
automatically to your HTML tag
the CSS that you wrote in global.css so
basically I can also remove this and
there we go and we see that I don't have
any class written in my elements and I
already got my style applied let's pass
to The Encore here we'll get an anchor
and there is no href so what I'm gonna
do I'm going to put an href to this
anchor and let's say that we want to go
to https slash
freecodecamp.org and I just have the
Cure saw pointer applied as a class what
I would like to have actually is that
all my anchor got a specific class and
style apply so I'm going to use apply
and I want them to be underlined so when
I get back suddenly I got an underline
and I want them to have a specific color
so what I can do is to go on the colors
okay of telwyn CSS so I go on
customizing colors and there we go we've
got here plenty of examples
and what I would like to have is some
kind of blue color like this so what I
could do is get back and I have
installed intellisense
intellisense with Tailwind it's the
plugin that I'm using right now that
gives me actually uh there we go this
one that gives me actually the classes
that I can use with Tailwind so when I'm
going to type the text blue color here
down there we see that I got all the
colors that are available if you had
later colors in your Tailwind config.s
in this intellisense extension will
understand that this color has to be
recorded and going here into the
autocomplete so I'm going to put text
blue 600. and when I get back there we
go I got my anchor on blue but let's say
that when I pass my mouse on it I would
like to have a text
yes purple okay so what I can do is here
adding directly okay sorry here hover
and I want to have text purple and
another color 500. all right so when I
get back and I pass my mouse on it
suddenly it passes to the purple color
all right the thing is here I want it to
be
Smooths I can just add transition
the transition class here to say yeah I
want that I got a nice transition okay
when I pass my mouse on it and we see it
it's a little detail but it's working a
lot on the experience
there we go we've got an anchor that has
its own style let's say that I want to
change maybe the decoration
so I'm going to go on the text
decoration here and I'm going to get
back there and I got text decoration
style and there we go let's say that I
want to have a decoration wavy on every
link of my website so what I'm gonna do
of course is to add the decoration wavy
and there we go I got a nice decoration
wavy added there I want to work on the
offset so the size between the text and
the decoration so I can use underline
offset and I'm going to put underline
offset and I'm going to put four to
start let's work now on the button okay
so the thing is that I will have several
button on my application and those
buttons will have very different
Behavior
what I want to do so I don't want to
Target all buttons I want to Target
buttons with classes so here I'm going
to add a class name and here it's going
to be BTN to start because all my
buttons are going to have a specific
basic class to start so right now I'm on
CSS of course with scss you could do
nested CSS but here just for this course
I'm going to stay on CSS so here button
okay I will apply a class and let's just
start by a basic thing the basic thing
is that we started with a blue color for
our anchors
and let's say that we want to stick to
this blue color there so what I can do
is to say yeah apply I want to add a BG
blue and exactly the same color as the
anchor
so when I get back
there we go we've got the background but
we see that there's a problem because
with our anchor we've got the offset up
there
it's not often that we're gonna have
this um hanker with the button there so
basically it's not really a problem
however what we would like to deal with
is the offset size there okay so we've
got it there on the top so I'm gonna get
back and what I can do is that I wrapped
my button in the div
so I can just add some margin on the top
and on the bottom and this will be
margin for to give us a little breath
and there we go Okay so we've got the
button there and how button what is it
we want that every button get the same
proportion but not the same color
however here it's a problem because I
put BG blue 600 so I'm going to remove
this BG blue 600 okay and instead I'm
gonna work on uh the padding and the
margin but to do that I first need to
put a background for you to understand
where is the padding and mounting so
actually I'm going to create a second
class and I'm going to go there and I'm
going to get back on my button and I'm
going to hide the button primary okay
button primary because if you want to do
a SAS you will have nested CSS
so here I'm just going to add this this
way there we go
and here this is where I can add
actually my BG blue 500.
and when I get back I got my BG blue 500
it was 600 sorry not 500 600.
there we go
the thing is that we have button there
and I'm gonna work now on the padding
because I want my button to have rounded
corners and some space on the top on the
on the left on the right on the bottom
so I what I can do to start is to say
the padding on the horizontal and there
I'm going to put a PX4 and on the top
I'm going to put a py3 to start okay
when I get back there we go I got this
big button
maybe there's too much space so I can
still work on the top and the bottom and
there we go we've got something nice
what I want to have also is a rounded LG
because I want it to be a bit rounded
and there we go that's really cool now
let's create another button so I'm going
to copy paste this division with the
button there and I'm going to create a
button secondary so here I'm going to
say this is a primary button this is the
secondary button
so we got now two different bottom and
there we go when I update
we see that suddenly we irritated from
the BTN class but not from the primary
so what I could do is get back there and
I could create this button secondary
open there and here I'm going to apply
another color so I'm going to apply for
instance we've got slate and I can say
that I want to have some kind of gray
button this way and when I get back
there we go but here there's a problem
there's a problem with the color of the
text so for both of them we're gonna add
a text white property and all the two
button will be suddenly on text White
that's great
now let's work that when we passes our
Mouse on it we want them to be
um
on the color under the the value we gave
before so we can get back there and type
hover and I want to have a BG blue but
this time let's try with 500 so when I
pass my mouse
there's this color that is slightly
changing okay we see that the color is
slightly changing and again like for the
anchor okay we want to have something
smooth so what we can add is transition
at the end
so I'm heading transition and when I
update
there's a little transition there and if
I want to work on the delay of the
transition so I can type
transition timing function what I can do
is here working on the duration I can
say that I want the duration to be
applied so I get back I get my button
and I want the duration to be applied on
my BG primary so here there we go
so duration 300 and when I pass my mouse
we see that it's slightly better but now
for our secondary button
it's a bit of problem because we will
have also to write all those classes
that we've got there and basically what
we would like to do is simply to say hey
on button hover
I will have this transition and duration
all the time so what I can do is to do
that on button hover I can okay apply
okay transition and duration 300 all
right and basically
if you want to really specify the color
we could say that instead of having a
hover on the color there we could say
just that we want to work on the opacity
so it's just a way of doing things and
I'm gonna say that I will get an opacity
of 80. so when I get back and I update
we see that it's working on the two
button which is amazing
but if you follow the course you know
that we don't need to do this other
thing what we can do is directly to put
it up there so I can put hover and on
over I'm gonna put a transition effect
so here there is no semicolon sorry
transition effect and here on Hover
again I want to have a duration
300 and hun hover again I'm gonna have
an opacity
800.
8 sorry 80. so I'm going to remove this
and it's also working so when I get back
and I pass my mouse there we go are two
buttons get this over effect
all right so that's really cool we just
created a design system for our button
really quick
um what we could do also is to work when
they are disabled so I'm gonna get back
there and I'm going to add a new button
and here this new button will be
actually on disabled okay so I'm going
to copy paste this and I'm going to go
there and this is a disabled button and
let's put it into a primary we need to
do is to say that the button is disabled
so I put the disable property on the
button and when I get back nothing is
happening instead that I don't get the
cursor pointer anymore I just got the
mouse that I can pass on it and on the
other they are able well now what we
want to have is a gray button and we
don't want to have this opacity effect
anymore so I'm gonna get back into my
CSS and here I get my button and I'm
going to type disabled and I want to
have a BG slate of 400 for instance so
when I get back suddenly my button is
gray but I still got this over effect
and I don't want it anymore so I can
stack do modifiers so I can say that on
Hover and if it's disabled I finally
want the opacity 100 so I want it to be
full and I don't want to have this
opacity anymore and there we go when I
pass my button
it's disabled I cannot have any over
effect anymore and actually this gray is
too gray okay the disable button is
supposed to have an opacity on it so I'm
gonna get back and on the color of BG
slate I'm going to say slash 50 and I'm
going to update and 50 is not enough
actually I gotta go to slash 30 and I
think it's good okay there we go now
we've got this button that is disabled
in comparison of the others okay here
we've got an input and we don't get
anything around it and the first thing
that we can see is that when I click on
it there is this outline this blue
outline and I wish we could remove it so
here what I can do is add a class name
which would be actually in here outline
known the outline known class will
remove okay we'll remove when I click on
it okay that's good but we don't see it
anymore so that's a problem
actually I'm going to get back on my
Global's CSS there and up there I'm
going to put input and inside type and
text there we go for now I'm just going
to start with that so I'm going to apply
outline known and I'm going to apply
also border because I want that my input
as a border and naturally we've got this
nice bottom
okay which is not very very nice what we
would like to have is a maybe a border
color
um more gray so I'm going to put just a
bit more of gray so border slate 300 and
there we go that's so cool that's nice
now I'm gonna add some rounded algae and
maybe rounded SM would be enough okay
yeah because as you see rounded LG it's
too big what I want to have is rounded
SM
yes I think that's good okay we don't
want to have something too aggressive
too rounded
all right but the thing is now we don't
get Space we see that the text is
actually beginning right
um on the letter on the left actually
totally on the on the left and right on
the border so what I want to do is to
add some padding so I'm going to add a
bit more of padding at first so here I'm
going to apply
px2 okay so I got a padding on the left
and on the right now I'm gonna have the
padding on the top and remember as I
told you try to work with double values
most of the time to get something more
clear okay if I unzoom and I get back to
100 here we see that got I get an update
and maybe this PX
is a bit too much okay it's maybe a bit
too much maybe I should put AP X1 and
finally what I can put is just to put a
P1 it depends on what you want to do but
this input should be good okay all right
that's cool now let's get back and let's
create a new input text but this time
it's going to be disabled what's gonna
happen if our input is disabled by
Nature our input disable is unclickable
and we've got a gray background on it
okay the thing is here on my input by
default for sure I want to put a margin
bottom of one because I don't want to
have anything that sticks to my input
so I already got this and yeah well the
thing is here I'm going to add a new uh
disabled background and background is
going to be BG let's say 200. even if we
already got a gray one okay it's too
much let's say 100
yeah it's better okay here we see more
that it's disabled okay so up there I
got this and let's say that as a
placeholder so I'm going to get back
I'm going to add a placeholder and it's
going to be uh email for instance there
we go we got is it was on the actually
it was on the
on this one there we go up there we go
so I got email there let's say that I
want to have my placeholder on Italy
what I'm gonna do I'm going to type play
solder and here is going to be italic
I'm going to save this and there we go
we see now that is my placeholder is on
italic but type date can I work on it of
course so here I got my input type date
so what I'm gonna do basically is maybe
to keep a bit the same behavior okay so
I'm going to put input type date
and down there we will see what class
what are the class I will keep for this
so here I'm going to type apply and it's
going to be also outline non border
there we go I think it's going to be the
same as this okay so I'm going to add
this and what's going to happen there we
go we've got our input date here with
the same class the basic class so maybe
I can put this we will check that after
but maybe I can just take this class
there okay and say that all the input
will be like this so when I get back
okay I got all the inputs that have
applied this class so I can remove those
okay and now all my inputs will have as
a basis what I choosed before and that's
good to do that because sometimes you
want in your application to keep some
kind of coherence between elements you
want that all the elements that you have
such as this input get the same design
so if I'm changing one day the rounded I
just want to put rounded instead of
rounded SM and I think I'm going to take
that as you see it has been applied to
my input date and my input text let's
say that we would have an input number
it would be exactly the same so if I
want to change also the color of the
text I'm writing in I could directly do
it there so I'm going to type text slate
and I'm going to add a gray like this
and I'm going to save and we don't see
it that much but it's a bit gray so I'm
going to lower the grayness of it and
there we go and as we see here we've got
the class there when we have a check box
basically we have the input checkbox and
we have also the label next to it so
when I get back there I get my label and
my checkbox let's start with the
checkbox so we've got an input type
checkbox okay and nothing changed on it
so what I got to do is just to put an
input type and then check box there we
go and inside I'm going to apply a class
and I'm going to say that unchecked I
want to have a BG red 500. so let's see
and let's see what's going to happen and
we see that nothing is happening to work
we need to say first that we don't want
Daddy keeps is appear currents and for
that we are using appearance known so
you change the color by saying
appearance known then say checked and
the BG so I'm going to get back and when
I click we see that I don't got nothing
anymore I just got this little square
and I really ask myself what happened
there when saying that you don't want
any appearance you are removing also the
check this solution is not the best
because we are missing the check icon
inside so what we should do instead we
are going to remove this appearance
known and what we're gonna see is that
it's not going to change the behavior of
my checkbox it will stay in blue what I
would do instead is to use accents so
here I'm going to get the example accent
and here we're gonna put purple again
and let's put purple 500 and there we go
we've got accent purple 500 and when I
click there we go older color is
changing the color of my checkbox we
could do also that is that we got a
label there and we know that our input
is next to our label all the time so
what I could do is to just add a class
to my label because I will always know
that this label will be on the top of an
input or next to it to specify something
about the input so what I would do is
just to add a specific size so I would
say that I I would have text small and
then I would have a text slate and let's
say that it would be a bit gray so let's
go and let's see what's going to happen
okay I got it and next to my input tip
checkbox I will always put some kind of
margin so margin to the right margin two
maybe two is a bit too much I'm going to
put one and there we go and maybe maybe
I would add a bit of fonts so I would do
font and medium I would say medium yes
there we go that would be good okay so
now we've got a checkbox that's working
with the checkbox label there and let's
say that we're gonna add some lorem
ipsum to it okay a big big text
as we see there we would have the
checkbox that will be on top of our text
and that's not necessarily something
that we want
so just by using Tailwind we know that
we can use flex
or however it already happened that our
text was next to our checkbox and there
we go what's gonna happen is that with
flex it's going to cut a div in two
parts one part for the checkbox the
other part for the text
so what we have there is that we got the
checkbox which is on the middle of our
text element so we can inspect that and
when we inspect we see that our checkbox
is on the middle and of course the check
box has a margin that we don't
necessarily want to put items start
and what's going to happen is that the
flexbox is going to put our item on
first actually okay and here we got a
new problem the new problem it's that we
have our checkbox there okay we have a
checkbox there and we have the text that
is not beginning at the right line we
will need to begin at the basis what we
could do to align the text with the
checkbox it's too hard to label a
specific line eight so let's say that
we're going to put line eight and here
I'm going to put 4 because I know that 4
is 1 Ram when I get back here we see
that it's a bit better however our text
is very compressed so what we could do
is to play with the flex and say that we
want to align those two attempts or we
could play with the checkbox so I'm
gonna get back on the checkbox and if I
Define that this checkbox will be always
in this situation I can go directly into
my input type checkbox there and put a
margin top of one for instance and
suddenly I got something in the
situation that I don't want to be it's
not necessarily on the line so what I
could do is instead putting a 0.5 and
what's gonna happen now is that we have
our checkbox immediately and directly
on the line of my element so you see
sometimes we tear in CSS we can play
with elements just to get a design right
I'm going to put some margin on the top
and on the bottom to continue the course
and there we go here we are let's
continue now we've got a select and the
select it's a very good topic to work
with Tailwind CSS because there are many
selects that we could create the first
select that we could create is the
original select from HTML which is this
one so what I'm going to do I'm going to
get back to globals and there I'm going
to type my select and I'm going to apply
my class and first what I want to
irritate from it's these inputs because
remember
this input there as some space and stuff
so maybe what I could do is to use this
input outline etc etc so I'm going to
type this and there we go suddenly my
option take the size and the design of
the other inputs that's cool however now
I got two lines that looks exactly the
same
so what I could do is instead of having
those two elements there okay it's just
doing this what I could do is just to
put my select up there
so now my input and my select would look
exactly the same and it is working of
course you want if I want to do
something different
if I want to have uh some classes that I
had to my select now I can do it
directly in here so let's say that I
would have a padding right of eight
instead of what I'm irritating up there
there we go I got a select that got more
options there all right
another thing that we could do is to
create our own select and to create our
own select what I would do is beginning
by creating my own piece of components
let's imagine that later it will be in a
component and it will work this way what
I would do is that for now I'm going to
just
uh commenting this and here I'm going to
create a div and this div would have a
class name of Select okay
and there are what I would have is a box
and this div would be my first options
my selected option my selected option to
go on the bottom and here I'm going to
mix okay this selected there and I'm
going to say I want to apply block okay
if I want him to stay on holder line or
I want to apply inline block all right
and suddenly there we go okay it looks
like a select but it's not a select and
to be a select I would add also my uh
actually padding right sorry padding
write eight there we go and what I will
need to do is uh just that when I pass
my mouse on it I would like to have a
cursor pointer so I would do cursor
pointer and there we go and let's say
that I would like to have a background
effect so as always
I would use on Hover and I would had BG
slate and it would be a very low BG
slate there we go so now I pass on my
mouse and there we go okay I would like
also to add a transition to it okay
that's good then what I would do is to
have a list of options down there so
what I can say is that I will have a div
and in this div I will have option one
then option two then option three all
right so I got this happening right now
when I'm gonna click on my selected
option I will have this list triggered
there and remember with flex that's
exactly what we can do we would like to
have something like this so I'm gonna
get back and I'm going to say hey
actually it's going to be a client's
name of flex and it's going to be a flex
call and divide y so Flex call divide y
all right then I'm gonna get back and
there we go that's what's happening
however we see that we've got a big
problem the problem is that we are
irritating from the classes of the input
so we've got this padding inside that is
cutting my options and here it's the
same so what I would do is of course to
remove this select from there because
this is not exactly what I want right
now I'm I'm reserving this style to the
select and input however for the select
I would have basically to keep it as it
is so basically I'm going to copy paste
what I need for the custom select
so I'm going to take all of this
and I'm going to go down and it's going
to go here exactly on deselect there we
go what we want to do up there on nexgs
13 is to call use client then to use the
state of react and set a variable is
open on the use State Force so for now
our select will not be open and down
there what we do is that when we click
on my selected options so on the select
we are going to set is open on the
opposite value of its current state and
when it is open it's going to show a
list or not so when I get back and I
update when I click okay there we go
we've got actually the options there and
it's working very well however for the
design it's not that again so we need to
get back and to remove this padding and
margin that we have
and especially this padding right eight
so and the hover I think we can also
remove it because we don't want it for
now
and when we get back yes there we are so
the padding that we want to have
actually it's on every element there
okay so basically what we could do is to
put a class another class which would be
a select children okay so my select
option will not be anything and then a
value okay that will be set by default
so when I got up there what I need to do
is to create another select value
actually so select value and set select
value
there we go user state which will be by
default on option one all right
so I got my select value
and then here what I can put is my
select value as we see I got my option
and what I need to do is to put a with a
minimal width so here it's going to be
let's try 30 and when I get back okay I
got the width 30 it's almost the same as
this one so the first one it's going to
be of class child and here what I can do
is to say that select dot child will
have this padding so I'm going to apply
I'm going to apply what of course my PX
to py1
okay then I get back and there we go I
got something that looks a bit the same
I got my class child that has been
applied and as we see my options there I
can click and open or close what I would
like to do also is to add maybe this
child to every element there so let's
try class name
is equal to child and I update and there
we go we see that we've got all our
elements however we miss this border
that we could have there so what I can
do is just going to my here my ul and
just put a border T there we go and
let's see what's going to happen when I
click I got my border down there I'm
going to Target my select UL Li and I
can apply on Hover my BG slate let's say
100 so when I get back I click and when
I pass we see that I got this effect and
of course what I can do now I can say
that when I'm gonna click on it it's
going to change my selected value I can
do after is to create a function update
value with the set selected value that
will be received as a parameter which
will be a string here and of course when
I'm gonna click on a value I want to
close my select so what I would do I
would set as open on false so when I get
down on my list element I would say that
on click I would update the value with
the current value which here is just a
string for the demonstration
so when I get back I update I click on
my select and I click on option free and
suddenly I got option three if I go once
option two suddenly I got option two
however we missed a last thing and this
last thing is the arrow that we could
have here so what we're going to do we
are going to catch an icon and we are
going to set an effect to it because we
want that when we click our arrows go
from the bottom to the top so let's
catch an icon right now on icon.gs.org
I'm gonna search for an icon which will
be an arrow down all right and yes this
one is cool okay I got this row that I
got there and I'm going to just copy
paste do component which is actually a
SVG so back in my app what I'm gonna do
here is just to create a new file okay
it's going to be a row down on dot TS6
there we go and I don't think I uh
downloaded it as a TX TS there we go
okay so now I'm going to put that
and I got this Arrow so what I can do I
can just change your name okay I wrote
down all right and I'm going to import
this row just here next to my value so I
import my row and I put my row next to
my select value but the thing is right
now as we see this is not the effect
that I want so what I need to do is to
put this select value into a span and
here as a class name on my child I'm
just going to add a flex because I don't
necessarily to want it to have after
this okay I get the flex I want the item
Center and I want to justify between
because I want some space between my two
elements and there we go we've got our
select and when we click it is working
now I want that when I click I want to
rotate this arrow to the top and if I
get back to the official documentation
and I click on rotate I might want
something like rotate 180 degrees Okay
so so if I take this class and I get
back to my app
and I go to my arrow down which is here
what I would like to do is to add this
class directly in there and to rotate it
so here is a trick here I can create a
div with a rotate 100 and I'm going to
put the arrow inside of it so if I
update suddenly we see that I get my
arrow on the top but this is not what I
want I would like to create a
conditional class what I want to know is
that if it's open and if it's open I
want to rotate 180 otherwise I want to
rotate 0 I want to let it add its basic
state so I update and there we go it is
working we can add if we want some
transition to it so both of them we're
going to save that I'm going to update
and when I click
we've got a quick transition to it so we
succeed to create our own select
congratulations you have created your
first design system okay it was short it
was quick but it's enough to give some
identity to your website thanks to
Tailwind so now you can use all these
elements if you want to create your own
application and you can replicate all
these elements to create an entire
front-end application
one of the main core concept of terrine
CSS is utility classes
basically with HTML what should we do
and using a traditional approach for an
element you will first write HTML and
from parent to Children you will Target
these HTML element with classes
then what you will do you will write CSS
and dcss will be related to your HTML
element
so you will write one time CSS for one
element
with Terran CSS we get the same result
way faster with a lighter code base
because we are using utility classes
utility classes its classes already
provided by telwyn CSS to give the same
result but without writing any CSS
if you want to use flexbox padding Max
width margin background color border
radius with 8 Flags whatever you can
relate to the Tailwind CSS documentation
and just add yo classes this way so you
will ask me the question Guam why not to
use inline style instead of having those
classes
well telwyn CSS has many advantages over
inline Style
first you have a predefined design
system provided by Tailwind which means
that from the start if you don't want to
create a design system you can easily
use the pre-existing design system
then with tear in CSS you can focus on
responsive design from the start
so I give you an example you are
creating your application and you are
adding your classes for the desktop Tab
and mobile you can do it with responsive
design at the same time because Tailwind
is providing to you
breakpoint prefixes and those breakpoint
prefixes are simply media queries
here we see that we've got a width by
default and we want to change this width
by default when we reach the breakpoint
prefix medium which is 768 pixel I can
just add the modifier MD on front of it
and I will change the size when I will
be on Min width
768 pixels okay and you can do the same
with large x-large
etc etc
so Tyrion CSS is very useful to work
with responsive design immediately from
the start so you don't lose your time
writing first the CSS for desktop then
writing the CSS for responsive
I was talking about modifiers
but modifiers also work for hover focus
and all other element that you can have
in CSS let's give an example here I got
a button and when I pass my mouse on it
we see that the color is changing okay
it this is because I use the LTT classes
with a modifier hover and with the
modifier hover I can say change your
color
it's also working with focus and active
and it's also working with elements like
last hold and even okay here we've got
the the example we can just change the
behavior on when we want to Target the
first last element
etc etc it's also working with before
and after sudo element yes Tailwind work
with pseudo element and we can also
Target for instance the placeholder if
you want to put them in italic the list
markers that's an example or the
Highlight text here I want to change the
color of my highlight text I can do it
with Tailwind simply with the modifier
selection
the responsive breakpoints help us to
work with that because you can stack you
can stack actually the modifiers and the
utility classes which is very useful
but another topic where terrain CSS is
amazing it's it's dark mode with Terran
CSS you can add what we call the prefers
color schema you can have several
um different color schema to your
Tailwind team and you can use of course
the dark mode here we've got an example
we can say that in dark mode I want to
change a color background and I just had
a dock on top of it okay and that's
amazing because Tailwind CSS really
hacked this thing of having a dark mode
into your application or website
personally I use it all the time however
the real Force for me of Terror in CSS
it's its customization system
with terrine CSS you can customize all
of it all your framework actually you
can customize your team through a
tailwind.config.js file because Tailwind
is like an engine that will understand
what sizes what colors what font family
what borders you want to use and it will
build on the fly on its basis classes
the class that you need let me give you
an example
on your tailwind.config.js you will have
a team object which will contain the
screen size or the breakpoints that we
saw before but also the colors the font
family and if you want to keep the basis
of terrain and right on top of it you
can use extend and in extend just
rewrite what you just want to write
again
but if you want to create your own team
which is cool is that with the colors
you can say hey if there is no blue
color add this blue color and this is
the code of the color
and the engine of Tailwind will
dynamically create for you the
background the text color the borders
everything that is related to colors and
then you will just have later to type
text blue BG blue border blue etc etc
how amazing is this and since I have
started to use tailwind and use its
customization system I cannot work
without of course you can go way deeper
into the customization because with
Tailwind CSS you can just reuse your
style so here we've got an example
here we are targeting the layer base
after importing tailwind and we can
apply with The Decorator at and apply
the directive we can say hey I want to
create a class but I want that this
class is using an existing Tailwind
class you can do it with apply okay you
can go deeper by creating also your
component directly and using the
directive and function theme this
directive and function team is helping
you to Target
directly the basis of tailwind and say
hey I want the reference of the colors
and in the colors I want the white color
and that's sometimes very very useful it
helps you actually to have your custom
utilities and it helps you to add your
custom classes most of the time you see
that you are using the same classes and
stuff and you would like to gather them
into some class it's possible with apply
but also you could create a class with
apply and calling all the base that you
need from Tailwind plus adding your own
CSS so you can stack the base of
Tailwind plus your custom element and
your Custom Design if you want to go
deeper into the customization of
Tailwind you have also the option of
writing plugins in JavaScript
that will help you to basically change
your base or change your component and
utilities provided by Tailwind all right
here we've got a quick example on how I
can change all the H1 of my base my
components there and utilities down
there that's an example on how far you
can go to write CSS with telwyn and how
far you can customize it
how to trigger the dark mode with
Tailwind CSS here I got an xgs
application running
and the first thing I need to do is to
go to my tailwind.config.js and I need
to add the key value dark mode class by
doing this I'm going to tell Tailwind
actually to use the dark mode when I
will add a class and this class will be
actually the class Doc and this class
doc will be on the top level of my
application
so when I go to my layout.ts6 this is
where I want to put my class
so here what I'm gonna do at first I'm
going to give a dark Behavior okay to my
application so here I'm going to say
that on the body the class name here on
Doc I want to have a BG slate of 900 and
also what I want to have is unlock a
text white okay so how is dark mode
working actually what we need to do is
to add the class name doc now we added
this okay it's going to change
everywhere in our application actually
do classes depending on the modifier
dock which relate to the class name Doc
and now when I get back to my app
suddenly my background changed it
changed to the BG slate 900 and the text
White
when I get back and if I remove my class
name up there and I save and there we go
we have a white background again we are
on the light mode okay so what we need
to do is to create actually somewhere a
button to trigger light or dark mode and
this button actually will do what it
will add to our HTML uh First tag of our
application do class name doc
all right I've created a header
component with a button and this is the
button that will trigger our dark mode
so back in our application in my
component actually I've created three
new files
two files icon which are basically the
two icons that I will need so when I
will be on the light mode I will have
the moon icon and when I will be on dark
I will have the sun then I have created
this Adder component and let's take a
look at it because this is a quick
function that I created for you in order
to trigger your dark mode
so let's have an explication here I got
the adder okay and when I click I'm
triggering a function this function is
called switch mode and switch mode will
switch actually the dark mode
so I have created a state which is a
Boolean on undefined by default
and I'm going to switch actually this
Boolean value from True to false however
when I arrive on the application is
going to be on undefined all right so at
first it's on undefined and what I want
to do I want to use use effect
why because when I will switch the value
of dark mode from True to false I want
to give to my document element there the
class doc okay
and but what I want to do also is to put
on my local storage anytime why in short
previously if our user put a dark mode I
want to store it and when I unite the
application I want to set back to the
dark team okay so I'm putting this item
in the local storage however you see
that in my use effect based on the dark
mode so when I switch on on and off
we see that I got this condition if
there is a dark mode or if the dark mode
is false and I got this third condition
if the dark mode is on undefined and
this is the trick there the trick is
that when I um launch my application
at first we will never enter into these
two condition because here dark mode
will be on undefined we will enter into
the latest condition which is Set Dark
mode and I will get the item dark mode
if it's on true along here it's a string
because uh actually in the in the local
storage we can't have Boolean we just
have string so there we go but here I'm
gonna say hey is there an item in the
local storage called Dark mode and is it
on true
if there is no item it will set dark
mode on false so we won't change our
theme however it will set it to true
and here you see that I don't get any
JavaScript return with window document
document element class list remove
why because remember our use effect is
based on dark mode and if I switch dark
mode inside this use effect it will
trigger again my use effect so here if I
got force or if I get true the value
here is going to change and I will enter
again into the use effect and this time
I will enter only in these two
conditions all right and in this two
position if it's true it's going to turn
to dark if its fault is going to turn
two false okay so let's have a try there
I'm going to open my console and we see
that I already got dark mode on first if
I click it pass on true if I click again
and pass on false etc etc now I'm
staying on dock and I'm going to update
my application
and Magic we stay on dark
but there's a last thing you need to do
if you want this to work
back in the layout
in your class name what you need to do
is to say to your application hey
check if on the local storage there is a
dark mode if there is one put it on true
otherwise put it on light why because
when you create your header and you put
it here on the top of your children
the time the application is going to
read from the top to the bottom it will
be on light so we you will have a side
effect it will be first on light then on
dark and we don't want that we want to
check at first if there is a an item
called Dark mode all right so as you see
it's perfectly working and it's amazing
because it gives a real good effect to
our application thank you for watching
this video I hope you really enjoy don't
forget to subscribe and see you soon